Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 14, Interface Description Languages. Take it away, Jason. Hey, so my Twitter and facebook account got hijacked no not good times yes i spent a significant amount of time today cleaning up uh you know tweets and posts that i didn't make and uh the archive forever somewhere yeah exactly so now uh coincidentally uh facebook
由Host Tornado提供主机托管服务。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和VPS解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第14集，接口描述语言。Jason，开始吧。嘿，我的Twitter和Facebook账号被劫持了，不，那段日子可不好过。是的，我今天花了大把时间清理那些我没发过的推文和帖子，而且那些东西会被永久存档在某处。没错，所以现在，巧合的是，Facebook
is uh sending me ads for russian models not just oh no but so was it better or worse than losing a wallet or have you ever lost a wallet before now i've never lost a wallet i did lose my keys but i lost them actually in a bottom of a lake so i've kind of figured that they weren't coming back and no one was finding them so one day somebody will drive away with your car after finding keys in the bottom of a lake yeah especially now well uh but uh but yeah basically um you know we talked about key pass which is an awesome program highly recommend especially now i highly recommend everyone use it um but i i wasn't using key pass you you know, for a while, especially before the show. And, uh, so I had like a default password that I used for things I didn't really care
正在给我推送俄罗斯模特的广告，不只是……哦，不。那么这比丢了钱包更糟糕还是更好？或者你以前丢过钱包吗？我从来没丢过钱包，但我确实丢过钥匙，不过我是把它们掉进湖底了，所以我知道它们找不回来了，也没人会发现它们。所以总有一天会有人在湖底找到钥匙后把你的车开走。是的，尤其是现在。嗯，但基本上，我们谈到了KeyPass，这是一个很棒的程序，强烈推荐，尤其是现在，我强烈建议每个人都使用它。但我有一段时间没用KeyPass了，特别是在节目开始之前。所以，我用了一个默认密码，用于那些我不太在意的
about, like Twitter and Facebook. Yeah. And it was just, it wasn't, it was just completely alpha characters. It wasn't a numeric or anything. And plus I use the same password for like basically everything I didn't care about. Like anytime I had to sign up for anything and so invariably you know somebody you know didn't store my password securely and uh you know got leaked out and associated my email and everything and so somebody just went through and systematically logged into everything that they could get into with that password
东西，比如Twitter和Facebook。是的。而且它完全是字母字符，没有数字什么的。再加上我基本上把我不在意的所有东西都用了同一个密码。比如任何时候我需要注册什么东西，所以总是有人没有安全地存储我的密码，导致密码泄露，并关联了我的电子邮件等等，所以有人就系统地登录了他们能用那个密码进入的所有东西。
and then it turned out you were in Europe asking for money after being kidnapped. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, so the way I found out was kind of interesting. I got an email from Facebook saying someone with an IP address they traced to Japan logged in successfully as me to Facebook. And so that kind of tipped me off. And so then I went went and sure enough, there were all these tweets on Twitter and Facebook posts that I didn't make and not to
然后结果是你人在欧洲，在被绑架后要求汇款。是的，没错。我发现这件事的方式还挺有趣的。我收到一封Facebook的邮件，说有人通过追踪到日本的IP地址成功以我的身份登录了Facebook。这给我提了个醒。于是我查看了一下，果然，Twitter和Facebook上有很多我没发过的推文和帖子，不得不
clean all that up. Oh man. Did anybody else let you know? Like, did any of your friends see what was going on? Oh no. So interestingly, this all happened really quickly. So basically, um, you know, all the tweets started, I would say like eight hours before I found out. Um, so, uh, you know, the tweets started, I would say, like eight hours before I found out. So, you know, the person like hadn't had enough time for it really to propagate to any of my friends or anything like that. And the Facebook posts were even more recent than that. So they didn't change your password, though, because that would have been bad because the recovery for your password would have been your email, which you then also didn't have access to. Yeah, that's true. Yeah yeah this could have been a disaster actually it's uh interesting you mentioned that because uh my co-workers uncle's uh yahoo account got hacked hijacked and they actually changed the uh you know forgot password like the backup email they changed that
清理所有这些。天哪。还有其他人提醒你吗？比如你的朋友有没有发现发生了什么？哦，没有。有趣的是，这一切发生得非常快。基本上，所有的推文开始发布，我想大概是在我发现之前的八个小时。所以，推文开始发布，我想大概是在我发现之前的八个小时。所以，那个人没有足够的时间让它传播给我的任何朋友之类的。而Facebook的帖子比那更近。不过他们没有更改你的密码，因为那会很糟糕，因为你的密码恢复方式是你的电子邮件，而你当时也无法访问它。是的，那是真的。这其实可能是一场灾难。你提到这个很有趣，因为我同事的叔叔的雅虎账号被黑了，被劫持了，他们实际上更改了“忘记密码”的备用邮箱，他们把它改成了
to an email that they owned like the hijackers and they changed the security questions and yeah depending on how and depending on the specifics of the system but yeah yeah it can be really bad yeah so actually they do have um so fortunately my gmail account was not hacked because it uses a completely different password um but they do have like a lot of these websites like facebook and google have what's called two-factor authentication and the way this works is you um you have a program running on your phone and basically whenever you have to put in your password to log into let's say gmail you also have to go on your phone and you hit a button and the button gives you a six digit number that you type in along with your password.
他们自己拥有的邮箱，也就是劫持者，他们还更改了安全问题。是的，取决于系统的具体情况，但这确实可能非常糟糕。所以实际上，他们确实有……幸运的是，我的Gmail账号没有被黑，因为它使用了完全不同的密码。但他们确实有很多像Facebook和Google这样的网站，拥有所谓的双重身份验证。它的工作原理是，你在手机上运行一个程序，基本上每当你需要输入密码登录Gmail时，你还必须在手机上按一个按钮，这个按钮会给你一个六位数的数字，你把它和密码一起输入。
And so the idea is for someone to hijack your account, they not only have to have, you know, your password, but they also have to have your phone. So that adds another layer of security. Yeah. And Google's, I think, actually, well, they have an option to either text you or call you if you don't have a smartphone oh that's cool i didn't know that yeah because i have it set up to call me i don't i don't remember why i did that this is kind of weird if i try to log in i get my phone will start ringing i'm like why is it ringing oh wait oh that's why and then it's coming up on screen like you know enter your your i think what they call otp yeah one time password yeah so so the so you actually get a call from google and they it just says like just as a random number or whatever you pick up it's like
所以这个想法是，为了让某人劫持你的账户，他们不仅需要你的密码，还需要你的手机。这增加了一层安全保障。是的。而且Google，我想，实际上，他们有一个选项，如果你没有智能手机，可以给你发短信或打电话。哦，那很酷，我不知道。是的，因为我设置的是让他们给我打电话。我不记得我为什么要那样做，这有点奇怪。如果我尝试登录，我的手机就会开始响，我会想“为什么它在响？哦，等等，原来是这样”。然后屏幕上会显示“输入你的……我想他们称之为OTP”，也就是一次性密码。是的，所以你实际上会接到Google的电话，他们只是说一个随机数字，或者无论你接听什么，它就像
this is your google verification code and then they say it once and then they repeat it that's pretty cool yeah it's kind of cool and i assume texting is probably similar just text you a six digit number yeah yeah totally yeah so so yeah i might set up a two-factor authentication um on things i really care about so that you know worst case if something like this happens and someone gets my password at least i'm still safe somewhat yeah the only hassle is and i guess this may be a different controversial subject well maybe not controversial i don't know but if you like uh your wife needs access to your email ever so it was the case where uh i think we've been communicating with our bank or with
“这是你的Google验证码”，然后他们说一遍，接着重复一遍。那很酷。是的，这很酷。我假设发短信可能也差不多，只是给你发一个六位数的数字。是的，完全一样。所以我可能会在我真正关心的东西上设置双重身份验证，这样万一发生这种事，有人拿到了我的密码，至少我还是安全的。是的，唯一的麻烦是，我想这可能是一个有争议的话题，好吧，也许不是有争议，我不知道，但如果你……比如你妻子需要访问你的电子邮件。有一次，我想我们一直在和我们的银行或某人沟通，
somebody and they had only been using my email for some reason and my wife needed like i needed her to print off some documents she was at home and i was at work and so she needed to get on my email and she knows my password but she didn't know my you know she couldn't have this this code and so she had to like like i had to get the phone call write the number down and then call her and give her the number so i guess that's really safe but you know it was kind of awkward that like i wanted her to be able to have access but in this way it was actually difficult to do that yeah yeah maybe oh man in hindsight what i should have done is actually just forward it to her but uh i guess this is controversial
出于某种原因，他们只使用了我的电子邮件，而我妻子需要……我需要她打印一些文件，她在家里，我在上班，所以她需要登录我的邮箱。她知道我的密码，但她不知道这个验证码。所以她不得不……我不得不接听电话，写下数字，然后打电话给她并告诉她这个数字。所以我想这确实很安全，但你知道，这有点尴尬，我想让她能够访问，但用这种方式实际上很难做到。是的，也许吧。天哪，事后看来，我应该直接转发给她，但我想这也有争议。
as well but you know it's like you worry about it's okay for me to do two-step authentication and i want to be really safe and have secure passwords and i you know try to educate other people the same way but you know you don't know. And so there's this hesitancy to like, I don't know. You don't know what other people's passwords are. You don't know if they're good. So you don't want to forward something to somebody who might have a, that may be very personal to you or have private information.
同样，你知道，你会担心……我进行双重身份验证并希望非常安全、拥有强密码是可以的，我也尝试以同样的方式教育其他人，但你不知道。所以会有这种犹豫，我不知道。你不知道别人的密码是什么。你不知道它们是否安全。所以你不想把可能对你非常私密或包含私人信息的东西转发给别人。
And then they don't have security like you would want. Yeah, yeah, totally. So actually, so the big thing to take away from here, folks at home, is because I'm pretty sure that what happened was I put my password in on some forum and somebody wasn't hashing the passwords and it just totally got leaked out. And I think even major websites like joystick.com had this whole thing where all of the passwords got leaked out like in plain text
而他们又没有你想要的安全性。是的，完全正确。所以，大家在家要记住的最重要的一点是，因为我很确定发生的事情是我在某个论坛上输入了我的密码，而有人没有对密码进行哈希处理，结果它就完全泄露了。我想即使是像joystick.com这样的大型网站也发生过这种情况，所有的密码都以明文形式泄露了。
so if you're gonna you know have a password which you don't really care about like if you need throwaway passwords use keypass just to recap what it does you have this master password you put it in and it opens up a program with just a list of passwords and it can auto generate passwords you can type in passwords. You can just make up passwords on the fly. It's sort of like writing your passwords down on a sheet of paper for the ones you don't care about. But that sheet of paper is now protected.
所以如果你要有一个你不太在意的密码，比如如果你需要一次性密码，使用KeyPass。回顾一下它的功能：你有一个主密码，输入它，它会打开一个程序，里面有一份密码列表，它可以自动生成密码，你可以输入密码。你可以随时编造密码。这有点像把你不在意的密码写在一张纸上。但那张纸现在被保护起来了。
It's better than just having it taped to attach to your monitor or something like that. Although I've actually heard somebody make an argument that it's better to write passwords like that down um so at least you guarantee they're different and you don't aren't encouraged to use the same one over and over again better to do that then then use the same password that's easy or the same oh yeah and you know just because that way you can remember it yeah but then of course if somebody breaks into your house they have all your accounts yeah that's true but if you um if someone breaks into your account if into your house you probably
这比把它贴在显示器上之类的要好。虽然我确实听过有人争论说，把密码写下来更好，这样至少你能保证它们是不同的，而且不会被鼓励一遍又一遍地使用同一个密码。这样做比使用简单或相同的密码要好。哦，是的，而且你知道，这样你就能记住它。但当然，如果有人闯入你的房子，他们就拥有了你所有的账户。是的，那是真的，但如果有人闯入你的账户，如果闯入你的房子，你可能
should just change everything like yeah that's true join the witness protection program but uh if if um yeah whether you write them down yourself or whether you use a program like keypass use a different password for every website that you don't care about because chances are if you don't care about it you know if you don't care about it you know it's probably they're not probably not doing a good job securing your password so don't be like me don't get all your things you don't care about hijacked and the bad thing is you know since i use the same password for everything i don't care about then basically like all of those things now can be compromised i mean like you know by their nature i don't care
应该把一切都改掉。是的，那是真的，加入证人保护计划。但如果……是的，无论你是自己写下来还是使用像KeyPass这样的程序，为你不在意的每个网站使用不同的密码。因为很有可能，如果你不在意它，你知道，他们可能没有做好保护你密码的工作。所以不要像我一样，不要让你不在意的所有东西都被劫持。糟糕的是，因为我对我不在意的所有东西都使用了同一个密码，所以基本上所有这些东西现在都可能被破坏了。我的意思是，就其本质而言，我不在意
about any of them but still i don't like the idea that someone's going on like the maim arcade forums masquerading as me or whatever you know although i guess that's maybe the least bad thing but yeah it's still kind of bad yeah yeah yeah so it's kind of a catch-22 it's like if i cared enough i i would have put a real password but then at the same time like i don't want somebody like well it's hard to because like each individual one you might not have cared enough about but now that like you said somebody can masquerade as you on many things that's actually more annoying yeah exactly exactly so all right the first news story i had one in here about and we talked about this a little bit before, about next generation consoles having this, you know, much more kind of a Valve type system where things are more downloaded and you put in unique keys and that key is tied to your console or your group, like your login. And so you can't, you know, just have normal CDs and stuff.
它们中的任何一个，但即便如此，我也不喜欢有人在像Maim Arcade论坛上冒充我之类的。虽然我想这可能是最不坏的事情，但它仍然有点糟糕。是的，这有点像两难境地。就像如果我足够在意，我会设置一个真正的密码，但同时，我不希望有人……好吧，这很难，因为每一个你可能都没有足够在意，但现在像你说的，有人可以在很多事情上冒充你，这实际上更烦人。是的，完全正确。好的，我这里有一个新闻故事，我们之前讨论过一点，关于下一代游戏机拥有这种更像Valve的系统，即更多内容是下载的，你输入唯一的密钥，该密钥与你的游戏机或你的组（比如你的登录名）绑定。所以你不能只使用普通的CD之类的东西。
And I just read an article about this is interesting so um sony has a storied past with hacker community and um the new their new handheld game system i think it was a new handheld on the psp vita um has this ability to go online and download games right like yay they're a little bit cheaper and you can go online you don't have to go to the store and they saw it as this wonderful thing well so of course uh just like uh people without a lot of scruples do on many different devices they essentially wrote a hack to get around this using an exploit and i think a combination of the game and the os um so one of the games that allowed you to kind of undo the drm the digital rights management
我刚读到一篇关于这个的文章，很有趣。索尼在黑客社区中有着悠久的历史，他们新的掌上游戏系统，我想是PSP Vita，有能力上网并下载游戏。对吧，它们稍微便宜一点，你可以上网，不必去商店，他们认为这是一件美妙的事情。好吧，当然，就像许多不同设备上那些缺乏顾忌的人一样，他们本质上编写了一个黑客程序，利用一个漏洞绕过了这一点。我想是游戏和操作系统的一个组合。所以其中一个游戏让你能够撤销DRM（数字版权管理），
that prevents you from running games which you don't have the key for and so um that might be a great oversimplification but anyway so what sony did was because they have this power that it's all online they you know pull those games down and then you know try to patch it and put them back up again and then upgrade the flaw that was exploited in the operating system as well and then force everybody to upgrade immediately so the thing that's kind of interesting is that had this been normal you know whatever generation or two ago a little less so with the current generation but still still could be done i guess is you have cds made or dv made, and you can't remake those DVDs. Somebody will always have that DVD with that exploit on it,
它阻止你运行没有密钥的游戏。所以，这可能是一个巨大的过度简化，但无论如何，索尼所做的是，因为他们有这种全在线的能力，他们撤下那些游戏，然后尝试修补它，再重新放上去，并升级操作系统中被利用的漏洞，然后强制每个人立即升级。所以有趣的是，如果这是正常的一两代之前，虽然当前这一代稍微少一点，但仍然可以做到，那就是你有制作好的CD或DVD，你无法重制那些DVD。总会有人拥有那个带有漏洞的DVD，
and the only thing you can do is force people to upgrade the firmware running on their devices. But this is even faster because they could pull it from the store and change it, force everybody to update both their game and their OS to be able to access anything online and essentially kind of stop it in its tracks. Yeah, right, right so that's pretty cool so so so it sounds like well can't you you can always just not upgrade right or no
而你唯一能做的就是强制人们升级设备上运行的固件。但这甚至更快，因为他们可以从商店中撤下它并更改它，强制每个人同时更新他们的游戏和操作系统，以便能够访问任何在线内容，并从本质上阻止它。是的，没错，这很酷。所以听起来，难道你不能总是选择不升级吗？或者不……
so the way they do it though and this is interesting is that so i you know this is outside the story now so this is patrick pontificating. Okay. But yeah, so I mean, the issue is... Double T. Ooh, I like it. The issue is that if you have this kind of online connectivity as like a base feature, so you're downloading games from the store, you're up, you know, there's all this digital rights management
他们这样做的方式很有趣，这是题外话了，这是Patrick在发表高见。好吧。但问题是……双T。哦，我喜欢。问题是，如果你把这种在线连接作为基础功能，比如你从商店下载游戏，你……你知道，所有这些数字版权管理
on your stuff as opposed to a disc, you would say like, oh yeah, just don't update. Well, the problem is they can force you to, right? Because the game, like Valve has this, you can not be connected to internet and play your Steam games, but only for a set amount you to, right? Because the game, like Valve has this, you cannot be connected to the internet
都在你的东西上，而不是光盘上，你会说，“哦，是的，只要不更新就行了”。好吧，问题是他们可以强迫你，对吧？因为游戏，就像Valve有这个，你可以在不连接互联网的情况下玩你的Steam游戏，但只能在一定时间内……对吧？因为游戏，就像Valve有这个，你不能连接到互联网
and play your Steam games, but only for a set amount of time or a set amount of plays, I don't remember. And then if you haven't connected to the internet, it won't let you play until you do connect to the internet. And then as soon as you connect to the internet, first thing they're going to do is, in order to play your game, you have to update
并玩你的Steam游戏，但只能在一定的时间或一定的次数内，我不记得了。然后如果你没有连接到互联网，它就不会让你玩，直到你连接到互联网。一旦你连接到互联网，他们要做的第一件事就是，为了玩你的游戏，你必须更新，
because Steam's out of date. And then once you update, boom, gone. Like you lost what it was. So I assume that playstation vita can do the same thing like they can if you go to play your game they'll say oh you haven't connected online in a month like you need to connect online or if you try to go online to play with your friends you know then they'll do the same thing because it's all through their system oh i see it kind of reminds me of and this is now jason pontificating because i have no idea how this
因为Steam过期了。一旦你更新，砰，没了。就像你失去了它一样。所以我假设PlayStation Vita可以做同样的事情，比如如果你去玩你的游戏，他们会说“哦，你已经一个月没联网了，你需要联网”，或者如果你尝试上网和朋友一起玩，那么他们也会做同样的事情，因为这一切都是通过他们的系统。哦，我明白了。这让我想起了……现在是Jason在发表高见，因为我不知道这个
technology actually works. But remember how they used to have those zips with the password on the zip? Yes. Yeah, you'd go to unzip it and be like, oh, nope, sorry, you need some password that's hashed into the zip. Otherwise, you can't get the contents. It's probably something like that, a with a temporal component to it you know like it's some kind of like zip hash thing but it but it's based on the current week let's say and so once the week expires like you don't have the password anymore kind of thing and you have to go and you know get
技术实际上是如何工作的。但还记得他们过去在zip文件上加密码吗？是的。你会去解压它，然后就像，“哦，不，抱歉，你需要一些哈希到zip里的密码。否则，你无法获得内容。”这可能就是类似的东西，带有一个时间组件，你知道，就像某种zip哈希之类的东西，但它是基于当前周的。所以一旦这一周过期，你就没有密码了，你必须去从索尼那里获取，
it from sony and sony will only give it to you if you know you haven't been compromised or whatever so yeah it's just tied to your account like yeah i think you're right so like it requires some some piece that exists in the operating system to basically unlock it and that piece of the operating system would be very hard for a hacker to write and so without it the game just says like hey i i'm calling this and it's not coming back like what's going on right right yeah i mean if you can make it to where the server has to be involved it's basically like hacking that would be the same as like hacking your bank password or something like that you know because you have to send some authentication out and then it has to get you know accepted on on the other end and then send back to you yeah i mean it's really the same as logging into a website so i mean and i think that was
而索尼只有在你没有被入侵的情况下才会给你。所以它只是绑定到你的账户上。是的，我想你是对的。所以它需要操作系统中存在的一些部分来解锁它，而操作系统的那个部分对黑客来说很难编写。所以没有它，游戏只会说，“嘿，我正在调用这个，但它没有返回，发生了什么？”是的，我的意思是，如果你能做到让服务器必须参与其中，这基本上就像黑客攻击，这和黑客攻击你的银行密码之类的东西是一样的，因为你必须发送一些身份验证，然后它必须在另一端被接受，然后再发回给你。是的，我的意思是，这真的和登录网站是一样的。
around forever. Right. Yeah. I mean, we could guess all day about, I guess, exactly how it's done. But it's just, to me, it was an interesting fact that this, as everything moves to online, the ability for them to take control out of your hands comes in. It's reminded of the, was it Amazon who pulled a version of 1982? Or 84, wait. Which is the one?
永远存在。没错。是的，我的意思是，我们可以整天猜测它是怎么做的。但对我来说，这是一个有趣的事实，随着一切转向在线，他们从你手中夺走控制权的能力也随之而来。这让我想起了，是亚马逊撤下了一个版本的《1982》吗？还是《1984》，等等。是哪一个？
Oh, yeah. 1984, the George Orwell. George Ororge orwell yeah george orwell wow 1982 is like our birthdays or something right no years no not mine but that's okay um okay confusion but they had somebody had published a version of that book that wasn't authorized and then people had i think it was free or people had paid a little and then amazon found out and they actually not just stopped selling it they went and took it away from everybody's device right right i remember that story which is yeah kind of like whoa whoa whoa hang on yeah basically it's like the book was not in public domain but
哦，是的。《1984》，乔治·奥威尔。乔治·奥威尔，哇。《1982》就像我们的生日之类的，对吧？不，不是年份，不是我的，但没关系。嗯，好吧，困惑，但有人出版了一个未经授权的那个版本的书，然后人们……我想是免费的，或者人们付了一点钱，然后亚马逊发现了，他们不仅停止销售它，还去把它从每个人的设备上拿走了。没错，我记得那个故事，这简直是……哇，等等，等等。是的，基本上就像这本书不在公共领域，但
like it was under some you could publish it for free but it wasn't public domain there was some license and like amazon like didn't agree with the license or whatever something like that yes so yes george orwell okay yeah yeah but yeah basically like yeah i mean steam and and you know it's it makes me wonder if if the whole like piracy hacking thing is going to just go away like for example you know now so many things are online the really the only thing that's going to be left to hack is like your os or something like that i mean i mean well okay we're using the term hacker here kind of doubly like there's a hacker of like hacker website what happened to jason yeah and then there are likely happened to jason
它是在某种你可以免费出版的许可下，但它不是公共领域，有一些许可，亚马逊不同意那个许可之类的。是的，乔治·奥威尔。好吧，是的。但基本上，Steam和……这让我怀疑，如果整个盗版黑客行为会不会就此消失？例如，现在这么多东西都在线，真正剩下的唯一可以黑的东西就是你的操作系统之类的。我的意思是……好吧，我们在这里有点双重地使用“黑客”这个词，比如黑客网站，Jason发生了什么，然后是可能发生在Jason身上的事情，
and then there's hacking like we're kind of talking about here which is more like subversion well that's a another thing but you know like you're doing something that the manufacturer doesn't want you to do but it's not necessarily illegal or you know attacking somebody else right right I guess I meant to say piracy when I said hacking yeah so the problem is there are legitimate reasons why you would want to do some of these things you bought the hardware like at some level you should have the rights to run what you want so like what if you just want to write run custom games so i saw this band the other day that was uh playing chip tunes which is like you know retro style game music um and they used a game boy so somebody had like designed a cartridge that you
然后是像我们在这里谈论的这种黑客行为，这更像是颠覆。好吧，那是另一回事，但你知道，你做了一些制造商不希望你做的事情，但这并不一定是非法的，或者攻击别人。没错，我想说的是盗版。所以问题是，你想要做其中一些事情是有正当理由的。你买了硬件，在某种程度上，你应该有权运行你想要的程序。比如，如果你只是想运行自定义游戏呢？所以我前几天看到这个乐队在演奏芯片音乐，也就是复古风格的游戏音乐，他们使用了一个Game Boy。所以有人设计了一个卡带，你
put in that is basically like a what are those things called a sequencer that you know you could play you know these tunes with on this game boy well i'm pretty sure that's not an official game boy cartridge so like but you know game boys how old and those people owned it they weren't taking any money from nintendo that i'm aware of you know like why should they not be allowed to make music on their game boys with this special game boy cartridge you know and at that level like i want to support them but the problem is that's a in my mind that's a small percentage of the people. Most people do these kinds of hacking to do piracy.
插进去，基本上就像一个……那些东西叫什么来着？音序器，你可以用这个Game Boy演奏这些曲调。好吧，我很确定那不是官方的Game Boy卡带。所以，但是你知道，Game Boy多老了，那些人拥有它，据我所知，他们没有从任天堂那里拿走任何钱。你知道，为什么他们不被允许用这个特殊的Game Boy卡带在他们的Game Boy上制作音乐呢？在那个层面上，我想支持他们，但问题是，在我看来，那只是一小部分人。大多数人进行这种黑客行为是为了盗版。
Right, right. So it's a hard line to walk. I mean, Google made that Google Maps for Nintendo, the NES maps. Oh, the April Fool's joke? Yeah, that's right. I'm pretty sure Nintendo didn't expect that when they released the nes no maybe not yeah well talking about cool hardware i'll uh i'll segue in here to a second story not to kind of take over from you and not give you any stories but this story is really cool so
没错，没错。所以这是一条很难走的界限。我的意思是，Google为任天堂制作了那个Google Maps，NES地图。哦，愚人节玩笑？是的，没错。我很确定任天堂在发布NES时没想到这一点。不，也许不是。好吧，说到酷硬件，我将过渡到第二个故事，不是为了从你那里接管而不给你任何故事，但这个故事真的很酷，所以
there's this website i don't know if we talked about it before kickstarter so it's kickstarter.com and the way this basically works is you pledge money to projects and then those if they reach a certain goal level of funding then your money gets collected if not then um you know you just keep your money nothing nothing transpires and so people post up ideas they have for projects they collect funding and then as part of that like if they can set levels of funding and if you pledge that level they agree to give you you know products you know, merchandise or if they're making a movie, send you a copy of the movie on DVD or maybe just online or whatever. But it's gotten a lot of attention recently with a bunch of video games, you know, going over a million dollars. I think there's like three or four video games now that have gone over a million dollars in funding for for the most part games that don't have a lot of nobody knows what they're going to
有一个网站，我不知道我们之前是否谈过它，Kickstarter。所以它是Kickstarter.com，它的基本工作方式是你为项目认捐资金，如果它们达到一定的资金目标，那么你的钱就会被收取，如果没有，那么……你知道，你保留你的钱，什么都不会发生。所以人们发布他们项目的想法，他们筹集资金，然后作为其中的一部分，如果他们可以设定资金水平，如果你认捐那个水平，他们同意给你产品，你知道，商品，或者如果他们正在制作电影，给你寄一份DVD电影，或者可能只是在线观看之类的。但它最近引起了很多关注，有一堆视频游戏筹集了超过一百万美元。我想现在有三四个视频游戏筹集了超过一百万美元的资金，大部分是那些没有多少……没人知道它们会
be it's just going to be so is it tim schafer from double games you know he made a bunch of cool games uh what full throttle grim fandango some other ones and he doesn't even know what game he's going to make he's just he's going to be awesome it's going to be like those and people like oh yeah here's millions of dollars yeah it's insane it's really exciting blows my mind i mean we need to like jump on this or something yeah maybe we should uh crowdfund uh programming throw down the movie starring jason gauchy as the fake mark zuckerberg you know what's cooler than oh no we won't start quoting movies from the social network ice cold oh no never mind all right so uh i wanted to talk about this thing
是什么的游戏。它只是……所以是Double Fine的Tim Schafer，你知道，他制作了一堆很酷的游戏，比如《Full Throttle》、《Grim Fandango》等等。他甚至不知道他要制作什么游戏，他只是……它会很棒，它会像那些游戏一样。人们就像，“哦，是的，给你几百万美元”。是的，这太疯狂了。这真的很令人兴奋，让我大开眼界。我的意思是，我们需要加入这个行列之类的。是的，也许我们应该众筹《Programming Throwdown》电影，由Jason Gauchy主演，饰演假马克·扎克伯格。你知道什么比……哦，不，我们不会开始引用《社交网络》里的电影台词，“冰冷”。哦，不，没关系。好的，所以我想要谈谈这个东西，
that i thought was really cool on here that has now raised 5. almost 7 million dollars as the time of this recording and i say time of this recording because it's going up like a rocket i think it broke a million dollars in a little over one day of being on here um and it's a e-paper watch for smartphones so it looks pretty cool a number of companies i guess have tried to do this before so what is it so apple kind of did this with like the ipod nano watch band thing or i don't know so what it is is a watch that you wear on your wrist and it's made the display is e-paper so it's just black and white but it's you know sunlight readable it's nice and it gives it i guess a longer battery life um and so it normally just displays the time but you pair it to your iphone or your android phone and if you get a text message um it'll display like
我觉得这里面真的很酷，截至录制时已经筹集了5.7百万美元。我之所以说“截至录制时”，是因为它像火箭一样上升。我想它在上线一天多一点的时间里就突破了一百万美元。这是一个智能手机的电子纸手表，看起来很酷。我想很多公司之前都尝试过这样做。所以它是什么？苹果公司用iPod Nano表带之类的东西做过这个，或者我不知道。所以它是一个你戴在手腕上的手表，显示屏是电子纸，所以它只是黑白的，但它在阳光下可读，很不错，而且它给了我更长的电池寿命。所以它通常只是显示时间，但你把它与你的iPhone或Android手机配对，如果你收到短信，它会显示……
the a summary of the text on your watch and has a little vibrating motor to signify you you got an alert you can sync it they have another one that shows like uh using it like a pedometer or showing a distance that you've run like while you're running um because i don't know if you've ever tried to run with a gps tracker on your phone it's actually kind of nice because it tells you distance and it's that sounds awesome speed but it's annoying to look at your phone while you're running especially if you have like strapped to your arm or something oh yeah right cool um you know and it can display different watch faces so you can customize it and they're they wrote like an sdk that they're gonna release for everybody to be able to write again so people can write apps and they showed a demo where you
短信的摘要在你的手表上，并有一个小振动马达来表示你收到了提醒。你可以同步它，他们有另一个显示……比如用它作为计步器，或者显示你跑步时的距离，因为我不知道你是否曾经尝试过带着手机上的GPS追踪器跑步。这实际上很不错，因为它告诉你距离，这听起来很棒，速度，但跑步时看手机很烦人，特别是如果你把它绑在手臂上之类的。哦，是的，没错，很酷。嗯，它可以显示不同的表盘，所以你可以自定义它。他们编写了一个SDK，他们会发布给所有人，以便人们可以编写应用程序。他们展示了一个演示，你
kind of just run the uh program on your phone and then you go to like their app store and i they don't really talk about it but i assume you'd be able to buy or hopefully a lot of them will be free you you know buy new apps for your watch through your phone that's totally awesome man so that's really cool um it's hard because you're laying out the cheapest one you can get right now is for a black one it's 115 i'm not a big watch person so to me that's kind of a lot for a watch. And you don't get it until September. So that's the only ones I have right now, I think are all prototypes. So you're kind of banking on like, that it'll be really awesome in that time. Like it's not normal, because normally you go on Amazon or wherever, look for reviews. But there are no reviews,
只是在手机上运行程序，然后你去他们的应用商店。我不知道，他们没有真正谈论它，但我假设你能够购买，或者希望其中很多是免费的，你知道，通过手机为你的手表购买新应用。这太棒了，伙计。所以这真的很酷。嗯，这很难，因为你现在能买到的最便宜的是黑色的，是115美元。我不是一个喜欢戴手表的人，所以对我来说，这对手表来说有点贵。而且你直到九月才能拿到它。所以我想目前我手头只有这些，都是原型机。所以你有点指望它在那段时间里会变得非常棒。这不正常，因为通常你会去亚马逊或任何地方查看评论。但没有评论，
because it doesn't really exist yet. It's just it's wild that they've raised so much money i mean i'm looking at it and like i'm literally i'm hitting refresh and every time i hit refresh they're raising thousands of dollars oh you're right it went up by ten thousand dollars and just since i'd had it loaded before yeah i mean it's just insane i mean like the amount of power behind kickstarter is just phenomenal i mean i've just never really seen anything like it like the news stories everyone that i see just blows my mind when you think about just the sheer volume of money that they bring in for these projects so imagine if you're a backer of this forget kick-starting the projects i wish i had kick-started kickstarter because like i mean they get a cut of all this money so like
因为它还不存在。他们筹集了这么多钱真是太疯狂了。我的意思是，我看着它，我真的在刷新，每次我刷新，他们都在筹集数千美元。哦，你是对的，它上涨了一万美元，就在我之前加载它之后。是的，我的意思是，这太疯狂了。我的意思是，Kickstarter背后的力量是惊人的。我的意思是，我从来没有真正见过像这样的东西。我的意思是，我看到的所有新闻故事都让我大开眼界，当你想到他们为这些项目带来的巨额资金时。所以想象一下，如果你是这个项目的支持者，忘了众筹项目吧，我希望我众筹了Kickstarter，因为我的意思是，他们从所有这些钱中分一杯羹，所以
they really yeah in the last couple months i i mean i think there's been over probably 15 million dollars i would guess very conservatively has gone through there so whatever their percentage of that is it's got to be huge oh my gosh it's just so insane it is real i mean it really is one of those things where in my opinion i might offend people or maybe i don't know the whole story there's nothing revolutionary about the technical background for doing this like this idea had been there yeah totally that it didn't need like a new technology or awesome programming or whatever but it's just a really really good idea and it hit at the right time
他们真的……是的，在过去几个月里，我的意思是，我想可能有超过1500万美元，我保守估计，已经通过那里了。所以无论他们的百分比是多少，那一定很大。天哪，这太疯狂了。它是真实的，我的意思是，这确实是那种事情，在我看来，我可能会冒犯别人，或者也许我不知道整个故事，在技术背景上没有什么革命性的东西。这个想法一直都在那里，是的，完全正确。它不需要什么新技术或很棒的编程之类的，但它只是一个非常非常好的主意，而且它在正确的时间出现，
so it got traction it wasn't ahead of its time. So everybody jumped behind it. And now it's like taking off. I'm really curious that like what the average project percent is, you know, like the average product, how fully funded is it? much the project's been funded and things like this and there are a lot of projects i've seen which get like almost no money like they are just kind of like what somebody because i think their standards like you have to get them vetted i think like you have they have to approve your project but then a lot of them are kind of like that's kind of silly or stupid and then nobody ever gives any money to it or like they raise 15 or something yeah yeah but it's awesome because it's a way for the project makers to gauge demand before they make something but as a consumer i'm kind of worried because you're buying something you have no idea what it's going to be like so even if they like let's assume something bad doesn't happen and they don't go under and not deliver you anything in which case i'm not sure
所以它获得了关注。它并没有超前于时代。所以每个人都支持它。现在它就像起飞了一样。我真的很好奇平均项目百分比是多少，你知道，比如平均产品，它的资金充足率是多少？项目筹集了多少资金之类的。我看到很多项目几乎没有得到任何钱，就像它们只是……因为我认为他们的标准是，你必须经过审查，我想，你必须让他们批准你的项目。但随后很多项目有点像……那有点傻或愚蠢，然后从来没有人给它任何钱，或者他们筹集了15美元之类的。是的，是的，但这很棒，因为这是项目制作者在制作东西之前衡量需求的一种方式。但作为消费者，我有点担心，因为你买的东西你根本不知道会是什么样。所以即使他们……假设没有发生坏事，他们没有倒闭，没有给你交付任何东西，在这种情况下，我不确定
where you're at because your money's gone they can't like they spent it and then they got hit by a disaster like i don't i don't know what happens in that case oh i thought that i thought that the whole point was that they don't take the money from you until like no they take the money when the funding ends oh but not when they deliver something oh wow see i was under the impression that basically both parties would have to agree like so for in other words for this watch thing you know if they say that for 120 you'll get a prototype of a watch then like you lose the money when you get the watch you know what i mean no no no you lose the money when like on this one may 18th i guess um they'll take the money from your account and then
你处于什么位置，因为你的钱没了。他们不能……他们花了钱，然后他们遭遇了灾难。我不知道那种情况下会发生什么。哦，我以为……我以为重点是他们直到……不，他们不从你那里拿钱，直到……不，他们在资金结束时拿钱。哦，但不是在他们交付东西时。哦，哇，看，我以为基本上双方都必须同意。所以换句话说，对于这个手表，你知道，如果他们说120美元你会得到一个手表原型，那么当你拿到手表时你就会失去钱，你知道我的意思吗？不，不，不，你在……比如5月18日，我想，他们会从你的账户中扣钱，然后
in september this company promises that they'll ship you something that's going to be awesome right but they don't have to i don't so i don't know legally they maybe have some obligation like but i don't know what kickstarter's involvement would be if that happened like on this one they'd probably want to get involved because it would be very drastic right but like you know if you fund something smaller or whatever i don't like they could deliver it to you but what if it just sucks or like what if it only lasts an hour instead of a you know a week like they say it's going to um on a battery charge what i mean what what are you to do about like i said you can't go online and read reviews first it's not actually made they're getting money so they can design it and make it and build it
在九月，这家公司承诺他们会给你寄一些很棒的东西，对吧？但他们不必……所以我不知道法律上他们可能有一些义务，但我不知道如果发生这种情况，Kickstarter会参与什么。在这个项目上，他们可能想参与，因为那将是非常激烈的，对吧？但你知道，如果你资助了一些更小的项目之类的，我不……他们可以交付给你，但如果它只是烂透了，或者如果它只持续了一个小时而不是像他们说的那样持续一周，电池充电……我的意思是，你该怎么办？就像我说的，你不能先上网阅读评论。它还没有真正制造出来。他们正在筹集资金，以便他们可以设计它、制造它并构建它。
it's it sounds like kind of like crowdsourced angel investing you know i mean it's basically what it is except the only thing is you know an angel investor expects to get like a huge return in this case you're expecting to get the watch before everyone else i don't know which i guess is a huge return because like if there's some people who really like it's like oh yeah i got the watch before everyone it's so cool you know what i mean so i have kickstarted one or two things um a board game that was kind of cool and i think maybe one other thing for like but it was much less money i think it was like 20 or something yeah um and it was a company that had done a kickstarter before and delivered well on it so i had a little bit more confidence oh is there like a feedback loop
这听起来有点像众包天使投资，你知道，我的意思是，它基本上就是那样。除了唯一的事情是，你知道，天使投资人期望获得巨大的回报。在这种情况下，你期望在其他人之前得到手表。我不知道，这我想是一个巨大的回报，因为如果有些人真的很喜欢它，就像“哦，是的，我在其他人之前得到了手表，这太酷了”，你知道我的意思吗？所以我众筹过一两样东西，一个棋盘游戏，还挺酷的，我想可能还有一样东西，但钱少得多，我想是20美元之类的。是的，而且那是一家之前做过Kickstarter并交付得很好的公司，所以我有一点信心。哦，有没有反馈循环？
uh well you can look it up, right? Like you can just Google the people or I think it tells you like how many projects they've like done. Oh, gotcha. But you can just like Google the company, Google the name and, you know, look for news stories. That's how I did it anyways.
嗯，你可以查一下，对吧？你可以直接谷歌搜索这些人，或者我想它会告诉你他们做过多少项目。哦，明白了。但你可以直接谷歌搜索公司，谷歌搜索名字，然后寻找新闻故事。无论如何，我就是那样做的。
But I'm hesitant. My philosophy on this one has become like they're saying in here, I think they said it'll retail for 150. So my thing is for my extra 35 i kind of rather wait and just buy it when it actually comes out yeah that's right yeah i mean for i mean if you put your money in like a cd or something actually i take that no no you'd have to get really if you have something that's that secure let me know you used to be able to make like eight percent on a cd but that was probably
但我很犹豫。我对此的哲学已经变成了，就像他们在这里说的，我想他们说它零售价是150美元。所以我的想法是，多花35美元，我宁愿等它真正出来时再买。是的，那是真的。是的，我的意思是，如果你的钱存入定期存款之类的，实际上我收回那句话，不，不，你必须……如果你有那么安全的东西，请告诉我。你过去可以在定期存款上赚取8%的利息，但那可能是
like 10 years ago yeah so oh man so you have though you have the next news article yeah so so this is a pretty fun it's pac-man running on the on a javascript implementation of the or i guess emulator of the zero x10 c cpu so okay you said a bunch of words i have no clue that anybody's gonna know what you're talking about let's take a step back so um minecraft the creator of minecraft notch they're making uh he's making a space game and i think you've done some research on this but i'll go into a little bit there's um there's a zero x10c CPU, which is this virtual hardware that you can control on your spaceship in this new space game that's coming out. So I don't have much more other than the game, I guess, is just, I assume you pronounce it OX10 to the C. I don't know.
10年前了。是的，所以……天哪，所以你有下一篇新闻文章。是的，所以这是一个非常有趣的故事，它是Pac-Man在JavaScript实现上运行，或者我猜是0x10c CPU的模拟器。所以，好吧，你说了一堆词，我一点头绪都没有，有人会知道你在说什么吗？让我们退后一步。所以，Minecraft的创造者Notch，他们正在制作一个太空游戏，我想你对此做了一些研究，但我会深入一点。有一个0x10c CPU，这是你在即将推出的这个新太空游戏中可以在你的宇宙飞船上控制的虚拟硬件。所以我没有太多其他的东西，除了游戏，我想，我假设你把它读作OX10 to the C。我不知道。
Yeah. And it's a space game. And in the space game, you have a spaceship, which has a fixed power supply generator of so many watts. And you mine something, I guess, from an asteroid or a moon. The details are kind of scarce right now. But on your ship, while you can use the CPU, which has a fixed number of speed and cycles and all this, you can use it to guide the ship.
是的。而且这是一款太空游戏。在游戏中，你有一艘宇宙飞船，它配备了一个固定功率的生成器，输出功率为若干瓦特。我想，你大概是从小行星或卫星上开采某种资源。目前细节还比较少。但在你的飞船上，虽然你可以使用 CPU（它有固定的速度、周期等参数），但你可以用它来导航飞船。
But if you're just sitting there waiting for some processing background task to run, you can play games on it. And of like making games himself like little mini games he released a specification for the processor this the d cpu 16 and people are now already starting to write application in games to run on this imaginary well well, real in-game spaceship CPU. Yeah, which is totally awesome. You know, this is actually, this is, I think, reaching the apex of something that has sort of really been brewing. I mean, you know, Notch himself has even admitted
但如果你只是坐在那里等待某个后台处理任务运行，你可以在上面玩游戏。他自己制作了一些小游戏，并为处理器发布了一份规范，即 D CPU 16，现在人们已经开始编写应用程序和游戏，在这个虚构的——好吧，其实是游戏内真实的——飞船 CPU 上运行。是的，这太棒了。你知道，我认为这实际上达到了某种酝酿已久的事物的巅峰。我的意思是，你知道，Notch 本人甚至承认
he's very influenced by Dwarf Fortress, which is a game released by Tarn Adams. You can actually download and play for free and door fortress is like a text-based version of minecraft believe it or not um yeah i mean it's actually there's actually even more going on in door fortress because you control like many different people instead of like a first person mode um but it's it's one of these games it's very abstract like very hard to visualize because it's literally ascii art and you're only looking at one sort of slice of the world so in other words like if you if you have a mountain you're looking at one slice
他深受《矮人要塞》（Dwarf Fortress）的影响，这是 Tarn Adams 发布的一款游戏。你实际上可以免费下载并游玩。《矮人要塞》信不信由你，就像是《我的世界》（Minecraft）的文字版。嗯，是的，我的意思是，实际上《矮人要塞》里的内容甚至更多，因为你控制的是许多不同的人，而不是像第一人称模式那样。但它是那种非常抽象的游戏，非常难以想象，因为它字面上就是 ASCII 艺术，而且你一次只能看到世界的一个切片。换句话说，如果你有一座山，你看到的只是一个切片。
of the mountain so you see this like ring of m letters or something right and as you use like the brackets to go up and down in the z levels basically the circle of m's gets smaller and like you just have to sort of in your head visualize yourself as like moving up through these like little slices of this mountain right so it's always really abstract games but but it had a lot of the fluid dynamics and things that you see in Minecraft. And one of the things that people did early on in Dwarf Fortress is actually make computers. And one person went so far as to make a Turing machine in Dwarf Fortress. And so for people who don't know, a Turing machine is, I'm probably going to butcher this, but it's basically the universal computational machine so the idea is if you can uh make a turing machine then a turing machine can can compute any problem or any algorithm that's computable that's computable right so anyway there's a lot of theory stuff that we probably shouldn't get into now but basically you know people were really into doing like computation in dwarf fortress and and uh that really you know someone
山的切片，所以你看到的是像一圈字母 M 之类的东西，对吧？当你使用方括号在 Z 轴层级上下移动时，基本上 M 的圆圈会变小，你只需要在脑海中想象自己正在穿过这座山的这些小切片，对吧？所以这些游戏总是非常抽象，但它包含了你在《我的世界》中看到的许多流体动力学等内容。人们在《矮人要塞》早期所做的事情之一，实际上就是制造计算机。甚至有人走得更远，在《矮人要塞》中制造了一台图灵机。对于那些不知道的人，图灵机是——我可能会说得不太准确——但它基本上是通用计算机器。所以这个想法是，如果你能制造一台图灵机，那么图灵机就可以计算任何可计算的问题或算法。所以，总之，有很多理论性的东西我们现在可能不应该深入探讨，但基本上，你知道，人们真的很热衷于在《矮人要塞》中进行计算，而且……有人
wrote a 10-bit adder and all this stuff so um and people have done that in minecraft too somebody wrote like an adder with sheep or something like that's bizarre somebody wrote a graphical calculator i saw a video of so like you can actually stand on buttons, enter an equation or whatever, and it'll plot it out on a screen in-game, like all these blocks that make up a computer screen. It's crazy. Yeah, it's totally amazing, right? So Notch is just taking it to the next level by saying,
写了一个 10 位加法器之类的东西。人们在《我的世界》里也做过同样的事，有人写了一个用羊组成的加法器之类的，这太离奇了。我看到过一个图形计算器的视频，你可以站在按钮上，输入一个方程什么的，它就会在游戏内的屏幕上绘制出来，就像所有这些构成电脑屏幕的方块一样。这太疯狂了。是的，这太令人惊叹了，对吧？所以 Notch 只是把它提升到了一个新的高度，他说：
all right, you guys, I'm going to just give you straight up a computer with assembly instructions and everything. And just the point of the game is to do fun things with this computer or or also really effective things like coming up with a clever ai to mine asteroids and things like that and it's really the interesting thing for me is you know i have a co-worker a guy who sits a couple rows from me and he's constantly working on like scripting mmos so he wrote a bunch of like bots for world of warcraft and uh he wrote uh a bot for uh what is it the star wars star wars knights of the
“好了，伙计们，我直接给你们一台带有汇编指令和一切功能的计算机。”游戏的重点就是用这台计算机做有趣的事情，或者做一些非常有效的事情，比如想出聪明的 AI 来开采小行星之类的。对我来说，真正有趣的是，你知道，我有一个同事，他坐在离我几排远的地方，他一直在编写脚本 MMO，所以他为《魔兽世界》写了一堆机器人，他还为……是什么来着……《星球大战：旧共和国》写了一个机器人……
republic or something like that okay yeah yeah he actually wrote a bot that like looks at the memory and then you know moves around and it can farm gold on its own and stuff like that. Knights of the Old Republic? No, that's a single player. Yeah, this is an MMO. I might be getting the name wrong, but it's a Star Wars MMO. Oh, yeah, just the Old Republic. Yeah, so he wrote, you know, basically an AI, a bot to play that game or to grind that game.
或者类似的东西。好吧，是的，他确实写了一个机器人，它会查看内存，然后四处移动，可以自己刷金币之类的。《星球大战：旧共和国》？不，那是单机游戏。是的，这是一个 MMO。我可能记错了名字，但它是一个星球大战 MMO。哦，是的，就是《旧共和国》。是的，所以他基本上写了一个 AI，一个用来玩那个游戏或在那个游戏中刷怪的机器人。
And so it's just interesting for notch to come out with this game and say look you know the point of the game is to write the bot to play the game you know it's sort of it's so meta i love it so that was robocode oh yeah remember that oh yes robocode is totally awesome so okay robocode you were talking about writing the bot to play the game that is literally what robocode was it was. So, okay, Robocode, you were talking about writing the bot to play the game. That is literally what Robocode was. It was a tank that were in an arena, and you had like a special set of Java that you could write that would say what the tank should do.
所以 Notch 推出这款游戏并说“看，游戏的重点就是编写机器人来玩游戏”，这很有趣。这太元了，我喜欢。那是《Robocode》。哦，是的，还记得那个吗？哦，是的，《Robocode》太棒了。所以，好吧，《Robocode》，你刚才说的是编写机器人来玩游戏，这字面上就是《Robocode》所做的事情。它是一个在竞技场里的坦克，你有一套特殊的 Java 代码可以编写，用来告诉坦克应该做什么。
Like the tank should scan its radar, and if it sees somebody, it should do this. And if it's this far away, it should behave like this, and it should rotate left and move forward. And you could just kind of program AI or something that just ran around and shoot randomly like you know you just program all sorts of things and then they would put them in giant tournaments the sorry they the online system you could play on your computer tournaments but you could also submit it online to run your code and they would run online tournaments where they would put everybody's
比如坦克应该扫描雷达，如果看到有人，就应该这样做。如果距离这么远，就应该表现得像这样，应该向左旋转并向前移动。你可以编写 AI 或类似的东西，让它四处乱跑并随机射击，你知道，你可以编写各种各样的东西，然后他们会把它们放入大型锦标赛中。抱歉，他们有在线系统，你可以在电脑上玩锦标赛，但你也可以在线提交代码，他们会运行在线锦标赛，把每个人的
different ones against each other and see whose was best yeah you know this this has come up a lot this kind of thing and the funny thing is it's always like the really stupid stupid simple algorithm that wins like like they had this uh what was it called again robo robo code robo code yeah they had this robo code and they were you know you have all these aspirations like oh someone's gonna write some crazy genetic algorithm neural network thing and it's just gonna like have this crazy ai it's gonna do awesome stuff and no it's like the guy who writes the code it says like turn left and shoot like wins and then they had this with mario too somebody made an open source clone of mario and they said write an ai to play mario um and sure enough the guy had this ai where basically he did uh a
不同的代码放在一起对战，看看谁的最强。是的，你知道，这种情况经常出现。有趣的是，总是那些非常愚蠢、简单的算法获胜。就像他们有这个……叫什么来着……Robocode，对吧？他们有这个 Robocode，你知道，你怀揣着各种抱负，比如“哦，有人会写出疯狂的遗传算法、神经网络之类的东西，它会有疯狂的 AI，会做很棒的事情”。结果不是，获胜的往往是那个写着“向左转并射击”代码的人。然后他们在《马里奥》上也遇到了这种情况，有人制作了《马里奥》的开源克隆版，他们说“写一个 AI 来玩《马里奥》”，结果确实，那个人用的 AI 基本上是
mini max which is an algorithm that they use for like playing checkers that's been around for like 50 years um and he beat everybody with like neural networks and everything like this guy who wrote this algorithm that was discovered you know 50 years ago just like just wins and they had uh something else where it was like this like open source uh it was like this uh open-ended world where you know you had this like population it was like this cellular automata kind of thing so there's a bunch of cells with people in them and uh you could like move forward you could turn you could mate and you could like move forward. You could turn. You could mate. And you could like kill. Like these are the four things you could do. And so like people realize genetic algorithms.
极小极大算法（Mini-max），这是一种已经存在了 50 年的用于玩跳棋的算法。他击败了所有使用神经网络的人。这个写了 50 年前发现的算法的人就这么赢了。他们还有其他东西，比如一个开源的、开放式的世界，里面有一个种群，就像细胞自动机一样。所以有一堆带有人的细胞，你可以向前移动、转向、交配、杀戮。这些就是你能做的四件事。所以人们意识到遗传算法。
They're trying to see if they could get like a group, like a wolf pack kind of thing to evolve. And, you know, the person who won, basically it's like turn left, try to have sex, and kill. Like that. Like and he beat all the neural networks and everything. And it's just like one thing after another it's like it's like always seems to be like these really simple algorithms take over which is really sad for ai people like us yeah well that's the like uh um game theory thing right that basically they did this thing where you could uh what is it i'm gonna mess it up iterative
他们试图看看能否让一个群体，比如狼群进化出来。你知道，获胜的那个人，基本上就是“向左转，尝试交配，然后杀戮”。就这样。他击败了所有的神经网络等等。这就像是一件接一件的事情，似乎总是这些非常简单的算法占据了上风，这对我们这些 AI 从业者来说真的很悲哀。是的，嗯，这就是博弈论的东西，对吧？基本上他们做了这个实验，就是……是什么来着……我可能会搞砸……迭代
prisoner's dilemma yeah that's right it's a basic one and everybody wrote all these algorithms to say like oh if we play over and over again this game with a choice like what should you do based on what the other person does and people came up with all these complex things like if he's doing this two times in a row then do the opposite constantly and it turned out the one that won was just tit for tat like just do whatever the other person did last time do next time yep yep so it's kind of sad but but you know i think it's a little humbling too so sometimes ai people we need to eat a slice of humble pie i guess that's why you just stay out of ai yeah yeah kids at home don't go to ai it just makes you sad no i'm kidding ai is great talking about uh computer research uh yeah so if you're gonna go into ai apparently you shouldn't go into it at uf right
囚徒困境。是的，没错，这是一个基础实验。每个人都写了各种算法，说“哦，如果我们一遍又一遍地玩这个有选择的游戏，根据对方的行为，你应该怎么做？”人们想出了各种复杂的策略，比如“如果他连续两次这样做，那就一直做相反的事”。结果发现，获胜的策略只是“以牙还牙”（Tit for tat），即对方上次做什么，你下次就做什么。是的，是的，所以这有点悲哀，但我认为这也让人谦卑。所以有时我们这些 AI 从业者需要吃点“谦卑派”（humble pie）。我想这就是为什么你远离 AI 的原因。是的，是的，家里的孩子们，不要去搞 AI，它只会让你难过。不，我在开玩笑，AI 很棒。说到计算机研究……是的，所以如果你要进入 AI 领域，显然你不应该去佛罗里达大学（UF）。
now the university of florida uh for those of us we probably shouldn't shorten too much so jason and i are both from the state of florida right but jason you didn't go to the university of florida you went to central florida university of central florida but i went to the university of Florida. Right. But Jason, you didn't go to the University of Florida. You went to? Central Florida. University of Central Florida. But I went to the University of Florida. So I guess this story has some sort of importance to me as UF is my alma mater. And the computer science department
现在，佛罗里达大学——对于我们这些人来说，我们可能不应该缩写得太多——所以 Jason 和我都是来自佛罗里达州的，对吧？但 Jason，你没有去佛罗里达大学，你去了中佛罗里达大学（UCF）。但我去了佛罗里达大学。对。但 Jason，你没有去佛罗里达大学。你去了？中佛罗里达大学。但我去了佛罗里达大学。所以我猜这个故事对我来说有某种重要性，因为 UF 是我的母校。计算机科学系
is facing budget cuts. And I guess they're going to try to put it under the electrical and computer engineering department. But this is controversial for a number of reasons, including like a bunch of researchers and teachers potentially will lose their job um but we want to take this opportunity to kind of talk a little bit about so the story to some people we were talking i was talking to and this is a little nuanced right like well why does it matter the program is not actually going away it's just going to be in another department like what does that really
正面临预算削减。我想他们打算把它归入电气与计算机工程系。但这引起了争议，原因有很多，包括许多研究人员和教师可能会失去工作。但我们想借此机会谈谈这个故事。有些人——我正在和他们交谈——这有点微妙，对吧？比如，“这有什么关系？项目并没有真正消失，它只是在另一个系，这真的有什么关系吗？”
matter and it led to this discussion about just all the different computer science degrees there are and how it varies school to school right so yeah what was your degree what was your undergraduate degree in jason yeah so my undergrad was in computer science and uh it was kind of tough for me because because because ucf as well as uf they have computer actually i don't even know uf probably has even more than this but at ucf there was computer science there was computer engineering and there was electrical engineering which had some programming in it and then there was also management information systems which had programming like and a lot of computer science prerequisites but was like a different program it has more for like people who are doing business right like in the was it in the business school or um no actually so it was more geared towards it okay yeah so it was a lot more about like networking servers that kind of thing
这引发了关于所有不同计算机科学学位的讨论，以及它们在不同学校之间有何不同。所以，是的，你的学位是什么？你的本科学位是什么，Jason？是的，我的本科是计算机科学。这对我来说有点难，因为 UCF 和 UF 都有计算机……其实我甚至不知道，UF 可能比这更多，但在 UCF 有计算机科学、计算机工程和电气工程（其中包含一些编程）。然后还有管理信息系统（MIS），它有编程，还有很多计算机科学的先修课程，但它是一个不同的项目，更多是为那些从事商业的人准备的，对吧？比如在商学院？或者……不，其实它更多是面向 IT 的。好吧，是的，所以它更多是关于网络、服务器之类的东西。
yeah so all of those people take a very similar course load but they are different uf has the same but i yeah well at least we used to have more so you had you could do a digital arts and sciences which is like for people in art, but want to do programming as well, like programming for 3D renderers or people doing it. So we had that. We had one that was in the business school that was for people who wanted to be able to do
是的，所有这些人学习的课程非常相似，但他们是不同的。UF 也有同样的情况，但我……嗯，至少我们过去有更多选择。你可以选择数字艺术与科学，这是为那些从事艺术但同时也想做编程的人准备的，比如为 3D 渲染器编程。所以我们有那个。我们有一个在商学院的，是为那些想要能够做
like SQL queries and scripting and also be able to be business people and do more analysis and stuff. Then we had computer science, which was a liberal arts degree. We had then we had computer science which was a liberal arts degree we had computer science in engineering which was a degree i got which is the same as the uh liberal arts degree but you have a little bit extra engineering background as opposed to uh like a foreign language uh you know more liberal arts type oh wow that's wild then so
SQL 查询和脚本，同时也能够成为商业人士并进行更多分析的人准备的。然后我们有计算机科学，这是一个文科学位。我们有计算机科学，这是一个文科学位；我们有工程类的计算机科学，这是我获得的学位，它和文科学位一样，但你多了一些工程背景，而不是像外语之类的更多文科类型。哦，哇，那太疯狂了。然后
then there was computer engineering software emphasis which was also in the computer science school um and that was you have a few more electrical engineering classes than computer science electives and then computer engineering hardware emphasis which had even more like you got into kind of semiconductor design and stuff so even more electrical and hardware and that was in the electrical engineering department, but they also had to take programming classes. So, and then there was, I guess you could get, even the college isn't the electrical engineering college,
还有计算机工程软件方向，它也在计算机科学学院。那里的电气工程课程比计算机科学选修课多一些。然后是计算机工程硬件方向，它有更多……你进入了半导体设计之类的领域，所以有更多的电气和硬件内容，那是在电气工程系，但他们也必须参加编程课程。所以，然后还有，我想你甚至可以获得……学院甚至不是电气工程学院，
it was the electrical and computer engineering college. Oh, wow. Yeah. So maybe we'll take turns giving our take on the whole thing because I went through this process and it was really difficult for me to decide which to pick. You you know there's a lot of allure in being an engineer like you know uh it's sort of like cool like if you think you picture engineers as people who like build things make things happen like the space shuttle is up there because engineers things
它是电气与计算机工程学院。哦，哇。是的。所以也许我们可以轮流谈谈我们对整件事的看法，因为我经历了整个过程，对我来说决定选哪个真的很难。你知道，成为一名工程师有很多吸引力，比如……这有点酷，如果你认为你把工程师想象成那些建造东西、让事情发生的人，比如航天飞机之所以在那里，是因为工程师……
like that i thought they were train drivers okay most people don't get that joke and they just look at me funny oh man those are siege engineers but anyway so um then there's you know so so that was kind of cool so that kind of made me think i should do computer engineering but then i looked at the course load and i saw at least at ucf computer science was sort of more math heavy and computer and physics and yeah, math and theory heavy and computer engineering had more like physics and like like dynamics and statics and those kind of things. So it's sort of more applied. And I was always sort of more interested in the theoretical part. So that's that's that's what sort of drove me to choose computer science. And then for the master's, I did, then, you know, for a master's degree, you have to kind of specialize. So I did graphics. And then for the doctorate, I did machine learning.
那些……我以为他们是火车司机。好吧，大多数人听不懂这个笑话，他们只是奇怪地看着我。哦，天哪，那是攻城工程师。但无论如何……所以……这很酷，所以这让我觉得我应该做计算机工程。但我看了课程表，我发现至少在 UCF，计算机科学在数学、物理和理论方面更重，而计算机工程有更多物理和动力学、静力学之类的东西。所以它更偏向应用。而我一直对理论部分更感兴趣。所以这就是促使我选择计算机科学的原因。然后对于硕士学位，我做了……然后，你知道，对于硕士学位，你必须进行专业化。所以我做了图形学。然后对于博士学位，我做了机器学习。
Show off. But basically, the takeaway is what I've learned is that computer science, if you really like more of the math, the number crunching, if you like what programming languages are made of, what constitutes a good language, all the different automata and things like that, those are the kind of things that you can only get in computer science like those are very computer sciencey things you know as opposed to like learning how to program which you'll learn in either one you can be proficient in programming totally computer engineering has more of the guts like like i noticed that patrick is much better than i am at like things like you know microprocessors and you know like embedded understanding like actually what's going microprocessors and, you know, like embedded understanding, like actually what's going on under the hood and like how to set up like circuits and things like that. I mean, I, I'd never learned any of that stuff. So, um, you know, so it really kind of depends on what you're interested in, but neither one is really better than the other. And I've been asked this question
炫耀。但基本上，结论是我学到的是，计算机科学，如果你真的喜欢更多的数学、数字运算，如果你喜欢编程语言是由什么构成的，什么构成了好的语言，所有不同的自动机之类的东西，这些是你只能在计算机科学中获得的东西。你知道，这些是非常“计算机科学”的东西，而不是像学习如何编程——你在两者中都能学到，你可以在编程方面变得精通。完全正确。计算机工程有更多的“内脏”，比如我注意到 Patrick 在微处理器和嵌入式理解方面比我好得多，比如实际上在底层发生了什么，以及如何设置电路之类的东西。我的意思是，我从来没学过那些东西。所以，你知道，这真的取决于你对什么感兴趣，但两者并没有谁比谁更好。我被问过这个问题
as well, um, that I'll try to answer here too, and we'll kind of move on so we don't bore the people who are uh long out of college um but the yeah so i think is in my experience at you know working in companies and talking to other people in the end it doesn't matter so much what your specific degree was in fact some schools don't even offer so many choices they only offer one computer science degree and it's an engineering or it's not an engineering. And the emphasis isn't so much about that, but as to what electives you take, as to what your outside of school interests are, as to what you do on your own time, as to what kind of job you take as your first job, like these kinds of things typically matter more. And when you get to a big, at least a big company, and I'm sure it probably even applies
以及……我也会在这里尝试回答，然后我们会继续前进，这样我们就不会让那些早已离开大学的人感到厌烦。但是的，所以我认为根据我的经验，在公司工作并与其他人的交谈中，最终你的具体学位是什么并不那么重要。事实上，有些学校甚至不提供那么多选择，他们只提供一个计算机科学学位，要么是工程类的，要么不是。重点不在于此，而在于你选修了什么课程，你的校外兴趣是什么，你在业余时间做了什么，你第一份工作是什么，这些事情通常更重要。当你进入一家大公司时，至少是一家大公司，我相信它可能甚至适用于
to small companies as well. there's not really a distinction. Like Jason and I, if we worked at the same company, then, you know, we would have the same title for the most part if we were at the same level. It wouldn't be different because he's more of a, you know, high-level applications guy and I'm more of a low-level embedded guy. Like we would still typically be the same job function at most places. Yeah, totally, totally totally so it doesn't matter as much as do what you're interested in like do what intrigues you more and what you find more uh fun to do because that's how you'll be engaged that's how you'll get good grades and that's how you impress a uh employer yeah i mean notice neither of us really mentioned like oh
小公司也是如此。并没有真正的区别。就像 Jason 和我，如果我们都在同一家公司工作，那么，你知道，如果我们处于同一级别，我们大部分时间会有相同的头衔。不会因为他是高层应用人员而我是底层嵌入式人员就有所不同。在大多数地方，我们通常仍然是相同的职位职能。是的，完全正确，完全正确。所以这并不重要，做你感兴趣的事情，做你觉得更有趣的事情，因为那样你才会投入，那样你才会获得好成绩，那样你才会给雇主留下深刻印象。是的，我的意思是，注意我们俩都没有提到“哦，
you know i went to computer science because it made more money or because I read something on CNN or because, you know. So, yeah, I think to Patrick's point, you should really do what you want. And then, you know, you can always, if you do what you want, then the rest sort of comes easy, you know. It's like if you are having fun and you're doing something that you really enjoy, then everything else will sort of fall into place. And then we're moving on, but I'll caveat it with one last thing,
你知道，我选择计算机科学是因为它赚的钱更多，或者因为我在 CNN 上读到了什么，或者因为……”所以，是的，我认为对于 Patrick 的观点，你应该真正做你想做的事。然后，你知道，你总是可以……如果你做你想做的事，那么剩下的事情就容易了，你知道。就像如果你玩得很开心，并且你在做你真正喜欢的事情，那么其他一切都会各就各位。然后我们要继续前进，但我会用最后一件事来提醒一下，
which is I will say that it does make sense to take practical classes. So a certain amount of things you want to be able to go to your first job and know how to do stuff. So if it's not a requirement, software engineering as the process of doing that um it is important to take some sort of low level class so you at least halfway know what's going
那就是我会说，参加实践课程是有意义的。所以你想要能够去你的第一份工作并知道如何做事。所以如果这不是要求，软件工程作为一种过程……参加某种底层课程很重要，这样你至少能半懂你在调试东西时发生了什么。
on when you're debugging stuff um it is important to do you don't want to do just things that are interesting and fun you want to do stuff that you think um will make you easier to hire for a bigger number of potential employers yeah that's fair something, you got to weigh those two. You can't do too much of one or the other. Yeah, yeah. Oh, that's definitely true. Yeah, I mean, there's, you definitely have to know
参加这些课程很重要。你不想只做有趣和好玩的事情，你想要做一些你认为会让你更容易被更多潜在雇主雇佣的事情。是的，这很公平。有些事情，你必须权衡这两者。你不能做得太多或太少。是的，是的。哦，那绝对是真的。是的，我的意思是，你绝对必须知道
how to apply what you're doing. I guess, you know, there's always the avenue of being a professor. But even professors nowadays are writing code, you know, or at least like helping out the process. A lot of professors maintain like a source code repository of like their researches work researchers work and things like that so yeah definitely you should have some applied background nowadays for sure so anyways
如何应用你正在做的事情。我想，你知道，总有成为教授的途径。但即使是现在的教授也在编写代码，你知道，或者至少是在帮助这个过程。许多教授维护着他们研究工作的源代码库之类的东西，所以是的，绝对的，如今你肯定应该有一些应用背景。所以无论如何，
let's get to tool of the bi-week all right you up first all, so my tool of the bye week is Sublime Text Editor. And basically, I've had to write a lot of JavaScript lately, which is something I'm completely unfamiliar with. Actually, we did a show on JavaScript, but I'm completely unfamiliar with writing in like a team environment. Usually if I do JavaScript, it's by myself, I'm hacking together some crazy client front end. I wrote a JavaScript front end for NetHack. But it's always been just kind of hobby products.
让我们进入双周工具环节。好的，你先来。好的，所以我的双周工具是 Sublime Text 编辑器。基本上，我最近不得不写很多 JavaScript，这是我完全不熟悉的。事实上，我们做过一期关于 JavaScript 的节目，但我完全不熟悉在团队环境中编写它。通常如果我做 JavaScript，都是我自己一个人，我正在拼凑一些疯狂的客户端前端。我为 NetHack 写了一个 JavaScript 前端。但它一直只是某种爱好产品。
I've never had to write JavaScript for a living. And so for the past couple of weeks, I've had to do JavaScript for a living in a production environment. And I had no real idea sort of what was a good IDE for doing JavaScript. And a couple of my coworkers recommended Sublime and yeah, I think it's pretty great. Might not be the best one out there, but it has like the kind of things you'd really like, the syntax highlighting, the color coding,
我从来没有为了谋生而写过 JavaScript。所以过去几周，我不得不在生产环境中为了谋生而编写 JavaScript。我真的不知道什么是一个好的 JavaScript IDE。我的几个同事推荐了 Sublime，是的，我觉得它非常棒。可能不是市面上最好的，但它有你真正喜欢的东西，语法高亮、颜色编码，
and all that stuff. One of the cool things, it has a pretty good sense at least for javascript so you can like click on a function and it'll take you to where you implemented it that kind of stuff also it has this cool mode where if you haven't edited a file it has this like the tab on the far left so it uses tabs like most ide's where you have like one tab for each file but they have one tab which is like all the files that like you haven't really edited yet and so like if you want to look through all your files it won't create a bunch of tabs like eclipse will you know like you can just like left click on all the files in the little explorer and go through them all without creating a bunch of tabs and then if you actually want a file to sort of be sticky,
以及所有这些东西。其中一个很酷的事情是，它对 JavaScript 有很好的感知，所以你可以点击一个函数，它会带你到你实现它的地方，诸如此类。它还有一个很酷的模式，如果你还没有编辑过一个文件，它在最左边有一个标签。所以它像大多数 IDE 一样使用标签，你每个文件有一个标签，但它们有一个标签是所有你还没有真正编辑过的文件。所以如果你想浏览你所有的文件，它不会像 Eclipse 那样创建一堆标签，你知道，你可以直接左键点击资源管理器中的所有文件，浏览它们而不需要创建一堆标签。然后如果你真的想让一个文件变得“粘性”，
to be a tab, you double-click on it. Or if you start editing it, then it'll split it out. But overall, the interface is really slick. Yeah, I've tried it out too, and I like that there's a little map down the right that shows you kind of like a high-level view of your code. So a lot of times you're trying to move really fast from like the top to the bottom of a file,
成为一个标签，你双击它。或者如果你开始编辑它，它就会把它分出来。但总的来说，界面非常流畅。是的，我也试过了，我喜欢右边有一个小地图，它向你展示了代码的高层视图。所以很多时候你试图从文件的顶部快速移动到底部，
and you kind of know what it looks like. It's just really easy to get there. And that's fun. And it's free to try, but they suggest if you keep using it, you should buy a license. Yeah. So basically, yeah. So if you every time you save, there's like a 1% chance you'll get a little nag window that you have to cancel, which like, you know, I used it for a couple of days before buying it. And I got the nag window
而且你大概知道它看起来是什么样子的。到达那里真的很容易。这很有趣。而且它是免费试用的，但他们建议如果你继续使用它，你应该购买许可证。是的。所以基本上，是的。所以如果你每次保存时，有 1% 的机会你会得到一个小提示窗口，你必须取消它，这就像……你知道，我在购买之前用了几天。我得到了那个提示窗口
maybe like three or four times so it's not too bad um but you know i highly recommend buying it i think it's only like i think it was like 10 bucks or something i bought it it's like 40 or 50 dollars really yeah oh man well yeah it's totally worth it 59 so that's a little expensive but if you work somewhere you know work should probably pay for that for you hopefully yeah yeah if you have an employer um and you're you're doing it as part of work you should definitely you know get it approved or whatever but um even if you do it on your own the nag screen isn't too bad um you know it's livable and uh the id is great but if you like it you should support the developers yeah definitely can't all be mooches yeah if you have the money uh you should
大概三四次，所以还不算太糟。但你知道，我强烈建议购买它，我想它只有……我想大概是 10 美元左右，我买了它。其实是 40 或 50 美元。真的吗？哦，天哪。好吧，是的，它完全值得。59 美元，所以有点贵，但如果你在某个地方工作，你知道，工作单位可能应该为你支付那个费用，希望如此。是的，是的，如果你有雇主，而且你是作为工作的一部分来做，你绝对应该，你知道，获得批准什么的。但即使你是自己做的，提示屏幕也不算太糟，你知道，是可以忍受的，而且 IDE 很棒。但如果你喜欢它，你应该支持开发者。是的，绝对不能都做“白嫖党”。如果你有钱，你应该
definitely buy it um or if you're self-employed and you're using it as part of your job you should definitely buy it yeah so what about your tool of the buy week getting off of my extended uh stay on non-open source uh things i'm finally back onto an open source project. Nice. Yay. And this one is a camera application called Luminance HDR, which stands for high dynamic range, or at least that's what it means in camera. I'm not sure. I hope specifically that's what it means in this app. And we have a link in the show notes.
绝对购买它。或者如果你是自雇人士，并且你把它作为工作的一部分使用，你绝对应该购买它。是的，那么你的双周工具是什么？摆脱了我对非开源事物的长期停留，我终于回到了一个开源项目。不错。耶。这是一个名为 Luminance HDR 的相机应用程序，代表高动态范围，或者至少在相机中是这个意思。我不确定。我希望这正是这个应用程序中的意思。我们在节目笔记中有一个链接。
And so this is basically, so the idea of a high dynamic range photo in the photography world is that if you take a picture um your camera does basically it tries to guess like how bright the picture should be so um it wants the average brightness of the whole image and this gets a little bit into image processing but through either mechanical or electrical me or electronic programming means uh it tries to determine like the average if you look think about like a piece of white paper if that was the only thing on your screen it kind of tries to make
所以这基本上是……所以摄影界高动态范围照片的想法是，如果你拍一张照片，你的相机基本上会尝试猜测照片应该有多亮。所以它想要整个图像的平均亮度。这有点涉及到图像处理，但通过机械或电气手段，或者电子编程手段，它试图确定平均值。如果你想一下一张白纸，如果那是你屏幕上唯一的东西，它会试图让
that like the middle of white like kind of gray you know kind of in the middle so that uh things to the top and bottom don't get washed out like that's what it wants to do so if you think about taking a picture with the bright sky in the background but like i take a picture of jason in the foreground in the shade. Sometimes like, how do you do that? Because the problem is you can only show so many bits, so much range, um, and your image. And the fact that I can't, I can show the dark of Jason in the shade and the bright of the sunlight, that's easy, but I want to both be able to see the details of Jason in the shade and also see that there's clouds in the sky yeah really the camera can only do one or the other it can only show the details on jason or show the clouds in the sky
它像白色的中间色，像灰色，你知道，在中间，这样顶部和底部的东西就不会被洗掉。这就是它想要做的。所以如果你想一下在背景中有明亮天空的情况下拍照，但我拍的是阴影中 Jason 的照片。有时，你怎么做呢？因为问题是你只能显示这么多位，这么多范围，在你的图像中。事实上，我不能……我可以显示阴影中 Jason 的黑暗和阳光的明亮，这很容易，但我想要既能看到阴影中 Jason 的细节，也能看到天空中云彩的细节。是的，真的，相机只能做其中之一，它只能显示 Jason 的细节或显示天空中的云彩。
i'm sure everyone's had this before where you know there's a sun in the background they try and take a picture of somebody and the person comes out like completely black like you just oh that's a great example yeah yeah or you try to take a picture of something and the sky is all washed out and glowy yeah yeah yeah so okay so those are the kind of the two options it takes right well the the limitation isn't really that the camera can't do either it's just it can't do them at the same or can't do both it just can't do them at the same time and so what hdr is about is taking the one where the foreground that's well it doesn't matter but the area that's dark dark and looks good when you take
我相信每个人都遇到过这种情况，你知道背景里有太阳，他们试图给某人拍照，那个人出来完全是黑的，就像你……哦，那是一个很好的例子。是的，是的，或者你试图拍某样东西，天空完全被洗掉并发出光芒。是的，是的，所以好吧，这些就是它采取的两种选择，对吧？嗯，限制并不是相机不能做其中任何一个，只是它不能同时做，或者不能同时做两者。所以 HDR 的意义在于，取一张前景……这没关系，但那个区域很暗，当你拍照时看起来很好，
an image just for the dark area and combining that with an image that is just of the bright area, but the dark area looks terrible. And you take both of those and kind of smash them together, right? And so what the computer can do is use a more bits of resolution for that range. So it can, instead of using an eight bit number to represent the amount of blue in the image it can use a 16-bit number to represent the amount of blue but your screen can't display that and your eye can actually do a better job but if the screen can't display it it doesn't matter and so what it does is use various algorithms to try to show both at the same time so kind of like i don't care about the middle so squeeze in the bottom and squeeze in the top and kind of ditch the middle um or just other things by combining those two images but the problem is
只为黑暗区域拍摄一张图像，并将其与一张仅为明亮区域的图像结合起来，但黑暗区域看起来很糟糕。你把这两者结合在一起，对吧？所以计算机可以为那个范围使用更多的分辨率位。所以它可以，而不是使用 8 位数字来表示图像中的蓝色量，它可以使用 16 位数字来表示蓝色量，但你的屏幕无法显示它，你的眼睛实际上可以做得更好，但如果屏幕无法显示它，那也没关系。所以它所做的是使用各种算法试图同时显示两者。所以有点像……我不关心中间部分，所以挤压底部和顶部，有点抛弃中间部分……或者通过结合那两张图像来做其他事情。但问题是
when you take two images you don't take them in exactly the same way if you're hand holding it they move slightly so you also have to shift the images so they are exactly the same on top of each other you get all sorts of bad things happen yep that's called registering the images that's right and when you have things that are misaligned you get ghosting so if like if a person is walking across the scene you get ghosting right okay but long story short this software does that no and it does it in a way with like many many different options all sorts of different algorithms all sorts of thresholds the user interface leaves something to be desired it's not always obvious what you should do and there are pay packages that do a really professional job of this.
当你拍摄两张图像时，如果你是手持拍摄，它们不会完全以同样的方式拍摄，它们会轻微移动，所以你还必须移动图像，使它们完全重叠在一起。你会遇到各种各样糟糕的事情。是的，这叫图像配准。没错，当你出现未对齐的情况时，你会得到重影。所以如果一个人走过场景，你会得到重影，对吧？好吧，长话短说，这个软件做到了这一点。而且它以一种带有许多许多不同选项、各种不同算法、各种阈值的方式做到这一点。用户界面有待改进，并不总是显而易见你应该做什么，而且有付费软件包可以非常专业地完成这项工作。
And once you know what an HDR image looks like, a really famous person is Trey Ratcliffe. He's an online personality, and he takes a lot of HDR images using very expensive, very nice software. But if you want to try it out yourself by, you know, kind of doing this example thing, there's a great way to do it with the software. And it really teaches you a lot about how it is actually being done as opposed to just doing it all for you, which is bad and good. Yeah, it's totally awesome. I mean, the great thing about this is that, as you said, it's free and open source. So, you know, there's nothing stopping someone from giving this a shot and learning something. Yeah. So I would encourage you to, if you're into photography or even if you're not just interested in image processing,
一旦你知道 HDR 图像是什么样子，一个非常有名的人是 Trey Ratcliffe。他是一个在线名人，他使用非常昂贵、非常好的软件拍摄了许多 HDR 图像。但如果你想自己尝试一下，通过，你知道，做这个示例，有一种很好的方法可以用这个软件来做。它确实教会了你很多关于它是如何实际完成的，而不是仅仅为你做所有事情，这既是坏事也是好事。是的，它太棒了。我的意思是，这个东西的好处是，正如你所说，它是免费和开源的。所以，你知道，没有什么能阻止某人尝试一下并学到一些东西。是的。所以我鼓励你，如果你喜欢摄影，或者即使你只是对图像处理感兴趣，
check it out. Yeah, totally. OK, so let's go into the programming language. We've sort of ranted for a while, so we'll try to be a little terse. But we're going to talk about IDLs, which is something, Interface Description Languages, which is something I'm really excited about.
去看看它。是的，完全正确。好的，那么让我们进入编程语言。我们已经抱怨了一段时间，所以我们会尽量简短。但我们要谈谈 IDL，这是……接口描述语言，这是我非常兴奋的事情。
I've only been using IDLs for like a little over a year now, but it's really helped my productivity tremendously to the point now where I use it no matter even for personal projects, hobbies, I almost start with the IDL programming first and then get into the rest of what I'm doing. So from a software engineering standpoint i mean interfaces you kind of alluded to starting with it it's not so much the interface description language we'll just say idl from now on the idl is the fact that it's the interface interface is the thing that glues all the parts of your project together if you're using a library
我使用 IDL 只有一年多一点，但它确实极大地帮助了我的生产力，以至于现在无论如何，即使是个人项目、爱好，我几乎都是先从 IDL 编程开始，然后再进入我正在做的其他事情。所以从软件工程的角度来看，我的意思是接口……你刚才提到了从它开始……它不仅仅是接口描述语言，我们从现在开始简称为 IDL。IDL 的事实是它是接口。接口是将你项目的所有部分粘合在一起的东西。如果你正在使用一个库，
how you interface with that library is very key. If you're going to interface to somebody else, that's like if you define those interfaces first, everything else somewhat falls into place. Right. And if you think about, you know, if you, you know, although it says interface description language, this is sort of it's sort of more general than that. It's also a lot of these are also sort of data description languages. And many programs that we write nowadays are sort of data driven you know the algorithms and the processes aren't necessarily new or interesting or difficult but it's just the data so you know for example like instagram or something like that you know picture taking had been around forever but the way that they manipulate the data with the social network and sharing with your friends and things like that is, well, one of the things that makes that product great. But there's also many other
你如何与该库进行接口是非常关键的。如果你要与别人进行接口，那就是……如果你先定义这些接口，其他一切都会各就各位。对。如果你考虑一下，你知道，如果你……你知道，虽然它叫接口描述语言，但这有点……它比那更通用。它也是许多这些也是某种数据描述语言。而且我们现在编写的许多程序都是某种数据驱动的。你知道，算法和过程不一定是新的、有趣的或困难的，但它只是数据。所以，你知道，例如 Instagram 之类的东西，你知道，拍照已经存在很久了，但他们处理数据的方式，通过社交网络和与朋友分享等等，是……嗯，使该产品伟大的原因之一。但还有许多其他
things. So that's kind of a tangent. But, you know, starting with the IDL lets you sort of lay out a framework for sort of how your program is going to flow not only in terms of processes and interfaces but in terms of the data and what's going to be stored and how that's a good point and and we should point out here people might be saying well why do I need a language for that and if you're only working on one process on one computer you might be right but these days like Jason alluded to even simple applications need to talk to another application or need to talk to another process or go over the network
事情。所以这有点跑题了。但是，你知道，从 IDL 开始让你能够为你的程序将如何流动制定一个框架，不仅是在过程和接口方面，而且是在数据和将要存储的内容以及如何存储方面。这是一个很好的观点，我们应该在这里指出，人们可能会说“好吧，为什么我需要一种语言来做那个？”如果你只在一台计算机上的一个进程中工作，你可能是对的。但这些天，就像 Jason 提到的，即使是简单的应用程序也需要与另一个应用程序对话，或者需要与另一个进程对话，或者通过网络。
and when you do that you need a way to tell the person on the other end who may be running on a different kind of computer a different operating system a different a different language and you need a way to tell them what your data looks like. Yeah, exactly. Yep. Or even if you're talking to disk, you know, if you want to save data to the hard drive, you don't really want to have... Yeah, serialize it or marshal it. You don't want to have to do that by hand. You want something that is going to generate that for you. So yeah, IDLs, how did they start?
当你这样做时，你需要一种方法告诉另一端的人，他们可能运行在不同的计算机、不同的操作系统、不同的语言上，你需要一种方法告诉他们你的数据是什么样的。是的，完全正确。是的。或者即使你是在和磁盘对话，你知道，如果你想把数据保存到硬盘上，你其实不想……是的，序列化或编组它。你不想手动完成这些。你想要一些能为你生成这些代码的东西。所以，是的，IDL，它们是怎么开始的？
Yeah, so I mean, there's some classic ones. You hear a lot about Corba, Common Object Relation. Oh, I'm messing it up. Common Object Request Broker Architecture. This is a classic one that's been around for a while. You hear a lot about. Another one that people might be familiar with if you program on Windows is the Common Object Model that Microsoft uses COM for a lot of communicating with its APIs and stuff.
是的，我的意思是，有一些经典的例子。你经常听到 Corba，Common Object Request Broker Architecture（公共对象请求代理体系结构）。哦，我搞错了。Common Object Request Broker Architecture。这是一个存在已久的经典架构。你经常会听到它。如果你在 Windows 上编程，人们可能熟悉的另一个是微软使用的组件对象模型（COM），用于与其 API 等进行大量通信。
And it's a way to describe how that data should be and what it looks like. Yeah, totally. So another one is ICE. That's made by the Zero-G. ICE is very similar to Corba. It came out around the same time under the mantra of, like, we're not as complicated as Corba. But it does functionally the same thing. So what are some of the ones that we may have heard of more recently?
这是一种描述数据应该是什么样以及它看起来是什么样的方法。是的，完全正确。所以另一个是 ICE。它是由 Zero-G 制作的。ICE 和 Corba 非常相似。它大约在同一时间出现，口号是“我们不像 Corba 那么复杂”。但它在功能上做的是同样的事情。那么我们最近可能听说过哪些呢？
Yeah, so that was the beginning was Corba and ICE, things like that. Then they moved on to sort of the early web era. There was SOAP and json rpc so basically the way these two work is you know at the time you know there was a xml and a json reader and writer in most modern languages so they said that this sort of could be an intermediary so since you know python can write XML and C++ can read XML and we just we should create some data format so you could think of like a
是的，那是开始，Corba 和 ICE 之类的东西。然后它们转向了早期的 Web 时代。有 SOAP 和 JSON RPC，基本上这两种工作方式是，你知道，当时大多数现代语言中都有 XML 和 JSON 的读取器和写入器，所以他们说这可以作为一种中介，因为你知道 Python 可以编写 XML，C++ 可以读取 XML，我们应该创建某种数据格式，所以你可以把它想象成一个
simple way to do something like soap is let's just have an XML file and if you have like a class like a C++ class or a Python class you just have a tag called class and attribute called name with the class name and then C++ class or a Python class, you just have a tag called class and attribute called name with the class name. And then inside of class, you could have many XML tags for all of the members of the class. And the tag could say, you know, member would be the tag name, and then the type, there'd be a type attribute saying whether it's like a double or a float or an integer or a character and then inside of the member tag you could
做像 SOAP 这样事情的简单方法，就是让我们有一个 XML 文件，如果你有一个像 C++ 类或 Python 类这样的类，你只需要一个名为 class 的标签和一个名为 name 的属性，属性值是类名，然后 C++ 类或 Python 类，你只需要一个名为 class 的标签和一个名为 name 的属性，属性值是类名。然后在 class 内部，你可以为类的所有成员设置许多 XML 标签。标签可以说，你知道，member 将是标签名称，然后是类型，会有一个 type 属性说明它是 double、float、integer 还是 character，然后在 member 标签内部，你可以
actually put the data so you could actually hold class instances as well as the definitions so that's one way to do to do soap X soap is one implementation of that so for example a C++ program can write out some classes uh using this xml format and then a python program could read this xml and then reinterpret it as python classes yeah so so maybe an example i think we're getting a little bogged down in uh acronym phobia or acronym uh too many acronyms flying around so so like let's say jason runs a service that shares pictures with the world or my friends and i am an application that runs on somebody's computer that wants to upload pictures to jason so an rpc is a remote procedure call basically
实际上放入数据，所以你实际上可以保存类实例以及定义，所以这是做 SOAP 的一种方法，XSOAP 是其中的一种实现，例如，一个 C++ 程序可以使用这种 XML 格式写出一些类，然后一个 Python 程序可以读取这个 XML，然后将其重新解释为 Python 类。是的，所以也许举个例子，我觉得我们在“缩写恐惧症”或“缩写”上有点陷入困境了，到处都是太多的缩写。所以，假设 Jason 运行着一个与世界或我的朋友分享照片的服务，而我是一个运行在某人计算机上的应用程序，想要上传照片给 Jason，所以 RPC 是远程过程调用，基本上是
saying like i want to be able to um initially take a picture that's on my hard drive and send information about like what the you who the user is when the picture was taken the picture itself like that data i want to send to Jason's web service so that he can then you know show it to the rest of the world so like how I call a function on his computer to say oh here I want you to upload picture and here's the data that's kind of the process that this stuff describes and then also the reverse like later i might want to pull down that image so i might want to make a call and say hey give me image number one and then have it give
说，我想能够……最初获取硬盘上的一张照片，并发送关于用户是谁、照片是什么时候拍摄的、照片本身等信息，我想把这些数据发送给 Jason 的 Web 服务，这样他就可以（你知道）把它展示给全世界。所以，我如何在他的计算机上调用一个函数说：“哦，这里，我想要你上传照片，这是数据”，这就是这些东西所描述的过程。然后还有反向操作，比如稍后我可能想把那张图片拉下来，所以我可能想打个电话说：“嘿，给我第一张图片”，然后让它把它
it to me or give me a list of all the images yeah totally and so then now more modern idls are sophisticated enough to where they'll actually generate the code for you for many different languages. So one of them is protocol buffers. And so what you can actually do, protocol buffers comes with a compiler. So you write your proto file, and the proto file will say, oh, I have a message, you know, picture, right? And picture has a string called name. And then it also has a you know a list of bytes called data right now you can run the c++ proto generator and it'll generate a bunch of
给我，或者给我所有图片的列表。是的，完全正确。所以现在更现代的 IDL 已经足够复杂，它们实际上可以为你生成许多不同语言的代码。其中之一是 Protocol Buffers。你实际上可以做的是，Protocol Buffers 自带一个编译器。所以你编写你的 proto 文件，proto 文件会说：“哦，我有一个消息，你知道，picture，对吧？”并且 picture 有一个名为 name 的字符串。然后它还有一个（你知道）名为 data 的字节列表。现在你可以运行 C++ proto 生成器，它会生成一堆
c++ code that can read and write these picture messages yeah class it'll generate a whole class with gets and sets for you. Right, so it'll have a get data, set data. It'll have a constructor where you could construct new pictures. And then you can also generate Java code. You can generate JavaScript code. You can generate et cetera, et cetera. In addition to the generator that generates this code,
C++ 代码，可以读取和写入这些 picture 消息。是的，类，它会为你生成一个带有 get 和 set 方法的完整类。对，所以它会有 get data，set data。它会有一个构造函数，你可以在其中构造新的图片。然后你还可以生成 Java 代码。你可以生成 JavaScript 代码。你可以生成等等，等等。除了生成此代码的生成器之外，
the protocol buffers also comes with a way to serialize so for example a way to convert it to like a binary representation so there might be some code for each language like some c++ code some java code which will say hey take this message which you know is a class as patrick mentioned and turn it into a set of bytes that can go into like a text file or go across the wire um and then also it says here's a set of bytes that i created or that someone else created using protocol buffers turn it into the class yeah and kind of in that step too which is a big gotcha of doing this on your own, is validating that what you got is actually a real class or is the thing that you meant it to be. Right, right.
Protocol Buffers 还提供了一种序列化的方法，例如一种将其转换为二进制表示的方法，因此每种语言可能都有一些代码，比如一些 C++ 代码、一些 Java 代码，它们会说：“嘿，获取这个消息（正如 Patrick 所提到的，它是一个类），并将其转换为可以进入文本文件或通过网络传输的字节集。”然后它还说：“这是我创建的或其他人使用 Protocol Buffers 创建的一组字节，将其转换为类。”是的，在这一步中，这也是你自己做的一个大坑，就是验证你得到的东西是否真的是一个真正的类，或者是否是你想要的东西。对，对。
And also handling, you know, if the protocol definition, if the proto changes, you know, dealing with that is also like brings a whole host of problems that you don't want to have to solve on your own. Right. to have to solve on your own. Yeah, I mean, if you've ever, you know, written a class and then written all these getters and setters and thought to yourself, like, there should be a way to do this automatically. Well, you know, that's exactly what, you know, these type of modern IDLs do is if you separate, as long as you can separate the logic from the data, then you can do this and not really have to ever write getters or setters or serialization or any of that it's all just done for you and so most modern programming nowadays you have these sort of container classes that just have a lot of data but can't actually do anything that are just auto
还有处理（你知道），如果协议定义，如果 proto 发生了变化，（你知道）处理这个问题也会带来一系列你不想自己解决的问题。对，不得不自己解决。是的，我的意思是，如果你曾经（你知道）写过一个类，然后写了所有这些 getter 和 setter，并对自己说：“应该有一种自动完成的方法。”好吧，（你知道），这正是（你知道）这些类型的现代 IDL 所做的，如果你分离，只要你能将逻辑与数据分离，那么你就可以做到这一点，而不必真正编写 getter 或 setter 或序列化或任何这些东西，这一切都是为你完成的。所以现在大多数现代编程中，你都有这些容器类，它们只是有很多数据，但实际上什么也做不了，它们只是自动
generated from some small proto file or thrift file which we'll get into later and then you know you have a set of handler classes that don't have any data or just have like a small amount of data but just manipulate these bigger container classes and send them across the wire write them to a database etc etc another modern idl and my personal favorite is apache thrift so actually this was started from the people who made protocol buffers and you can think of this as sort of like a version 2 of proto buffers but basically Thrift adds support for things like lists and sets and maps. The kind of things that you know people who have done Java or Python
从一些小的 proto 文件或 thrift 文件（我们稍后会讲到）生成的，然后（你知道）你有一组处理程序类，它们没有任何数据，或者只有少量数据，但只是操作这些更大的容器类并将它们通过网络发送，将它们写入数据库等等。另一个现代 IDL，也是我个人最喜欢的是 Apache Thrift。实际上，这是由制作 Protocol Buffers 的人发起的，你可以把它看作是 Protocol Buffers 的 2.0 版本，但基本上 Thrift 增加了对列表、集合和映射等事物的支持。你知道，做过 Java 或 Python 的人
who are familiar with lists or dictionaries in Python. Apache Thrift has native support for that. So in Thrift, for example, you can say, like, I have this Thrift message, and the message is gallery. And my gallery has, let's say, a name, which is the name of the gallery, maybe an integer, which is the ID for, you know, looking it up later. And then the third could be a map, which maps strings to picture objects. And so you can map like the name of a picture to the actual data. And all this is done in Thrift using just a few lines of this Thrift code. And then you can auto Generate that You know class in any language You want I think there's like 15
熟悉 Python 中的列表或字典。Apache Thrift 对此有原生支持。所以在 Thrift 中，例如，你可以说：“我有这个 Thrift 消息，消息是 gallery。”我的 gallery 有，比方说，一个 name，它是 gallery 的名称，可能是一个整数，它是用于（你知道）稍后查找它的 ID。然后第三个可以是一个 map，它将字符串映射到 picture 对象。所以你可以将图片的名称映射到实际数据。所有这些都是在 Thrift 中使用几行 Thrift 代码完成的。然后你可以自动生成那个（你知道）你想要的任何语言的类。我想大约有 15 种
Languages that are supported So oh go ahead yeah no no yeah So I mean yeah there's a there's a lot of Choices here um it's one of those Things when you I don't remember ever really talking About most of these in school it's Kind of something you learn when you get on the real world and you Start running across these recurring problems Of man i really need to talk to something
语言是支持的。所以，哦，请继续。是的，不，不，是的。所以我的意思是，是的，这里有很多选择。这是那种当你……我不记得在学校里真正谈论过这些。这有点像当你进入现实世界并开始遇到这些反复出现的问题时，你才会学到的东西：“天哪，我真的需要和某样东西对话，
else and i need to come up with a common way to represent it and uh i i'm gonna roll my own and then you run into a whole bunch of problems so it's much better to use one of these yeah i mean just to put it in perspective so one thing that i did sort of early on in my careers we we wanted to write a bunch of logging data of sort of like what the state of the system was at different points in time and we actually we had a bunch of classes in C++ that we we wrote just by using what's called a mem copy or f. So we actually just took the class in binary form and just wrote it to the hard drive as ones and zeros. And then on the other end, to read the class, we actually, you know, we had this file that had a bunch of classes in it. So you think, oh, well, I'll just write some program that just, you goes the other way and doesn't f read ah but the problem is one machine was big Indian and the other
而且我需要想出一个通用的方式来表示它，呃，我要自己写一个。”然后你会遇到一大堆问题，所以使用其中之一要好得多。是的，我的意思是，为了说明问题，我职业生涯早期做的一件事是，我们想写一堆日志数据，记录系统在不同时间点的状态。我们实际上在 C++ 中写了一堆类，我们只是通过使用所谓的 mem copy 或 f。所以我们实际上只是以二进制形式获取类，并将其作为 1 和 0 写入硬盘。然后在另一端，为了读取该类，我们实际上（你知道）我们有这个包含一堆类的文件。所以你想：“哦，好吧，我只是写一个程序，它只是反向操作并执行 f read。”啊，但问题是一台机器是大端序（big endian），而另一台
machine was little Indian and for people who don't know Indian means it's it's kind of like a pun it's Indian it's actually spelled e nd i a n and basically what it means is let's say you have a short so a short is a 16-bit number right it's a two byte number so the question is where should the number start like if you're writing a number in English like let's say you're writing the number 1000 well the number the the most significant part of the numbers on the left like the one in 1000 the biggest the number is on the left. Like the 1 in 1,000. The biggest part.
机器是小端序（little endian）。对于不知道端序的人来说，这意味着它有点像双关语，它是 endian，实际上拼写为 e-n-d-i-a-n，基本上它的意思是，假设你有一个 short，所以 short 是一个 16 位数字，对吧？它是一个双字节数字。所以问题是数字应该从哪里开始？就像如果你用英语写一个数字，比如你写数字 1000，好吧，数字的最高有效部分在左边，就像 1000 中的 1，数字最大的部分在左边。就像 1000 中的 1。最大的部分。
Yeah, is in the thousands digit. Or if you have the number like 222, the first two is the most significant. Like that has the 200, the big part of the number. If you lost the first two, that would be a big deal. If you lost the last two, it wouldn't really matter. You'd have 220 220 let's say so that in in the case of computers there are some computers which are big Indian and that is where the first byte of a number say you have a short that's two bytes the first byte has the most significant bits in it and the second byte has the smaller the least significant bits. Some
是的，在千位上。或者如果你有数字 222，第一个 2 是最重要的。就像它有 200，数字的大部分。如果你丢失了第一个 2，那将是一个大问题。如果你丢失了最后两个，那真的没关系。假设你有 220，220。所以，在计算机的情况下，有些计算机是大端序的，这就是数字的第一个字节（假设你有一个 short，它是两个字节）包含最高有效位，第二个字节包含较小的、最低有效位。有些
computers are little Indian which means it's the other way around. So the first byte has the least significant bits or the numbers that wouldn't really matter if they weren't there or if they were set to zero. So the computer that was reading the data was little Indian and the computer that was writing it was big Indian. So all of the numbers were just completely bogus. Like all of them were like the bits were reversed. So the numbers were the bytes were reversed. The numbers are just garbage. So we had to write all of this code. It was just thousands of lines of code to like byte swap all of these you know
计算机是小端序的，这意味着情况正好相反。所以第一个字节包含最低有效位，或者如果它们不存在或被设置为零，数字真的没关系。所以读取数据的计算机是小端序的，而写入数据的计算机是大端序的。所以所有的数字都完全是伪造的。就像它们所有的位都被反转了。所以数字是……字节被反转了。数字只是垃圾。所以我们不得不编写所有这些代码。这只是数千行代码，用来字节交换所有这些（你知道）
classes and byte swap all of the members in the classes, and it just, it took weeks. And if we had known about, you know, Apache Thrift or protocol buffers, we would have saved literally weeks, probably months of work. Yeah, definitely very useful. Yeah, I mean, there are just tons and tons of gotchas when it comes to moving, you know, turning code into data or turning, you know, the data that lives inside a code into ones and zeros, serialization and marshalling. And there's just tons and tons that goes into that. And so, you know, it's interesting to learn about, but if you just want to write something to disk, save yourself the trouble and use Apache Thrift.
类，并字节交换类中的所有成员，这花了数周时间。如果我们知道（你知道）Apache Thrift 或 Protocol Buffers，我们本来可以节省数周，甚至可能是数月的工作。是的，绝对非常有用。是的，我的意思是，当涉及到移动（你知道），将代码转换为数据，或者将（你知道）存在于代码中的数据转换为 1 和 0，即序列化和编组时，有成吨成吨的坑。而且其中涉及的内容非常多。所以（你知道），了解这些很有趣，但如果你只是想把东西写到磁盘上，省去麻烦，使用 Apache Thrift 吧。
So IDLs kind of are, this is different, as opposed to talking to one specific language, you're talking kind of about a group of languages, but they do share some common features. And some of it is the idea of this, this common idea of like the message, the thing that you might want to send or write to disk and generating these, you know, all this ancillary helper code that needs to be
所以 IDL 有点像，这是不同的，与只针对一种特定语言不同，你谈论的是一组语言，但它们确实共享一些共同特征。其中一些是这种共同的想法，比如消息，你可能想要发送或写入磁盘的东西，以及生成这些（你知道）所有需要完成的辅助代码。
done. And it's really nice that most of these provide utilities or are part of it where they process these message description files and generate code for you. Yeah, totally. The messages are huge. Another big part of it is most IDL support many different protocols. So for example Apache Thrift supports JSON so you can send it across over the wire as a JSON object and that's really useful for web debugging because you know a lot of web technology is sort of designed to expect JSON. It can also send data as binary so if you want to write the data to a file on your hard drive that you don't really care it to be human readable, you
而且非常好的是，大多数这些工具都提供实用程序，或者作为其一部分，它们处理这些消息描述文件并为你生成代码。是的，完全正确。消息非常重要。另一个重要部分是大多数 IDL 支持许多不同的协议。例如，Apache Thrift 支持 JSON，所以你可以通过网络将其作为 JSON 对象发送，这对于 Web 调试非常有用，因为（你知道）许多 Web 技术在某种程度上被设计为期望 JSON。它也可以将数据作为二进制发送，所以如果你想把数据写入硬盘上的文件，而你并不真正关心它是否是人类可读的，你
could do binary. Or if you want to store it in a database, you can use binary. Also many of these have what's called a compact binary, and this is where they do a lot of sort of processor intensive work to shrink the size down so this can actually have a dramatic effect so for example you know you might reduce your database size by two-thirds by using a compact encoding which you know if you're dealing with gigs and gigs of data and if you're using something like amazon elastic cloud or something this could save you a ton of money yeah um the nice thing is also that they each library kind of typically has code to handle the details of what is going out as so if you if you're serializing
可以做二进制。或者如果你想把它存储在数据库中，你可以使用二进制。此外，其中许多都有所谓的紧凑二进制（compact binary），这是他们做大量处理器密集型工作来缩小尺寸的地方，这实际上可以产生巨大的影响。例如（你知道），通过使用紧凑编码，你可能会将数据库大小减少三分之二，这（你知道）如果你处理的是数 GB 的数据，如果你使用像 Amazon Elastic Cloud 之类的东西，这可以为你节省一大笔钱。是的，嗯，好的地方还在于，每个库通常都有代码来处理正在输出的内容的细节，所以如果你像 Jason 所说的那样以一种端序序列化它，然后以另一种端序读回它，
it like jason said in one endian and then reading it back in another uh the protocol will actually have defined what that is. And so the readers and writers on both sides all have agreed on what that should be and what to expect. So you don't have to worry about it. That's right. So just for example, and I don't know if this is actually how it works, but, you know, the Apache Thrift might say, hey, if you're big Indian, then I'll byte swap everything before I send it out. Like everything will be in little Indian when it's in between computers or on disk. And that way it's sort of everyone has the same expectation, you know, and you don't have any crazy data. So the, I mean, some of the good,
协议实际上已经定义了那是什么。所以两端的读取器和写入器都同意那应该是什么以及期望什么。所以你不必担心它。没错。所以举个例子，我不知道这是否真的是它的工作方式，但是（你知道），Apache Thrift 可能会说：“嘿，如果你是大端序，那么我在发送它之前会字节交换所有内容。”就像在计算机之间或磁盘上时，所有内容都将是小端序。这样每个人都有相同的期望，（你知道），你不会有任何疯狂的数据。所以，我的意思是，一些好的，
moving on to strength, some of the good things about these are these, we talked about the automatic code generation, the ability to use whatever language you want whatever kind of computer you want whatever kind of operating system you want go across the internet those are really the and the time saving i mean these are all really good strengths of the ideas but what are some of the weaknesses yeah so there is a certain amount of engineering work that you have to spend i mean for one thing you have to learn this technology and everyone using it has to be aware of it um The other thing is that, you know, it's just like using compilers, just like using everything. It's not going to be as efficient as if you did it by hand, you know? I mean, this has been the argument since the beginning of time, right?
继续说优势，关于这些的一些好处是，我们谈到了自动代码生成，能够使用你想要的任何语言，你想要的任何计算机，你想要的任何操作系统，跨越互联网，这些确实是，而且节省时间，我的意思是，这些都是 IDL 的非常好的优势。但有哪些弱点呢？是的，所以你必须花费一定量的工程工作。我的意思是，首先，你必须学习这项技术，并且使用它的每个人都必须意识到它。嗯，另一件事是，（你知道），这就像使用编译器，就像使用所有东西一样。它不会像你手动完成那样高效，（你知道）？我的意思是，这是自古以来的争论，对吧？
Like, oh, if I wrote assembly by hand, it would be so much better. But, you know, there are cases, like especially, you know, let's say you want some real-time sensitive, like you're writing some plugin to do video conferencing or something like that. You probably want to write your own serialization that that takes advantage of certain nuances of your environment. So let's say you're doing sending video like compressing video you probably don't want to use apache thrift to compress video because video has certain characteristics like the human eye cannot really distinguish shades of blue and you want to take advantage of that you want to compress blue more than everything else these are the kind of things like you don't want to use uh an idl for
就像，“哦，如果我手动编写汇编，那会好得多。”但是，（你知道），有些情况，特别是（你知道），假设你想要一些实时敏感的东西，比如你正在编写一些插件来进行视频会议之类的。你可能想编写自己的序列化，利用你环境的某些细微差别。所以假设你正在发送视频，比如压缩视频，你可能不想使用 Apache Thrift 来压缩视频，因为视频有某些特性，比如人眼无法真正区分蓝色的深浅，你想利用这一点，你想比其他任何东西都更压缩蓝色，这些就是（你知道）你不想使用 IDL 的情况。
yep and also i mean if you're not careful, or like Jason said, if there's potential things that you know more about than the general solution, it can take longer. If you were going to write a very custom binary format, you might be able to make it smaller than what any of these things are able to do. So there might be overhead there that's associated with that yeah totally so um some good tools for uh doing idls um i use thrift for eclipse so basically it's it does like syntax highlighting and things like that i think it can actually run the thrift code generator for you so when you make changes to the thrift file it will auto generate the code um for me it's easier just to you know to run the command that generates the
是的，而且我的意思是，如果你不小心，或者像 Jason 所说的那样，如果有你比通用解决方案更了解的潜在事物，它可能会花费更长的时间。如果你要编写一种非常自定义的二进制格式，你可能能够使其比这些东西所能做的更小。所以可能存在与此相关的开销。是的，完全正确。所以，嗯，一些用于执行 IDL 的好工具，我使用 Eclipse 的 Thrift，所以基本上它做语法高亮之类的东西，我想它实际上可以为你运行 Thrift 代码生成器，所以当你对 Thrift 文件进行更改时，它会自动生成代码。对我来说，（你知道）运行生成代码的命令更容易，
code it's not that much work but i think you can you can with some elbow grease you can set it up to be sort of more streamlined another one is for protocol buffers is protoclips. And that's very similar, but for that format. Yeah. Yeah, definitely. So, I mean, very useful, very flexible. If you want to talk across the web, do remote procedure calling. If you want to serialize data to disk, if you want to just store something. Also, some databases, you know, have this language and are able to do kind of more intelligent things if they know in advance, like what, like the description of what your data is stored as.
它没有那么多的工作，但我想你可以，你可以通过一些努力，将其设置为更精简。另一个用于 Protocol Buffers 的是 Protoclips。这非常相似，但针对的是那种格式。是的。是的，绝对。所以，我的意思是，非常有用，非常灵活。如果你想跨 Web 对话，进行远程过程调用。如果你想将数据序列化到磁盘，如果你只是想存储一些东西。此外，一些数据库（你知道）也有这种语言，如果它们预先知道你的数据存储的描述，就能够做更智能的事情。
Yeah, these are really powerful things, something that not everybody knows about. They're not completely obvious, but when you learn about them, they're a great, great help. Yeah, I mean, if you've ever seen something that was sort of transformed to the web, like I saw recently like SSH on the web or something like that. Or you see these like video games like FreeSib, they ported it to the web. And you figure like, how is that possible? Like, did they rewrite all of this in JavaScript? You know, like, how is this running in my browser? Well, chances are the JavaScript is just some thin client, and it's using something like Thrift or protocol buffers to talk to some bigger program on the server
是的，这些是非常强大的东西，不是每个人都知道的东西。它们不是完全显而易见的，但当你了解它们时，它们是一个非常、非常有用的帮助。是的，我的意思是，如果你曾经见过某种被转换到 Web 的东西，比如我最近看到的 Web 上的 SSH 之类的东西。或者你看到这些像 FreeSib 这样的视频游戏，他们把它移植到了 Web 上。你觉得，“这怎么可能？他们用 JavaScript 重写了所有这些吗？”（你知道），“这怎么在我的浏览器中运行？”好吧，JavaScript 很可能只是一个瘦客户端，它正在使用像 Thrift 或 Protocol Buffers 之类的东西与服务器上的某个更大的程序对话，
that's running in C++ or Java or whatever. Well, I wanted to point out, well, finishing up with IDLs, we have a lot of great user feedback. We use our feedback, listener feedback. So we've had a great amount of reviews on iTunes. Thank you guys for those. We've had some good feedback on our Google Plus page. People have given us a lot of show topic ideas
该程序运行在 C++ 或 Java 或任何东西中。好吧，我想指出，嗯，结束 IDL 的话题，我们有很多很棒的用户反馈。我们使用我们的反馈，听众反馈。所以我们在 iTunes 上收到了大量的评论。谢谢你们。我们在我们的 Google Plus 页面上收到了一些很好的反馈。人们给了我们很多节目主题的想法，
that they want to hear about, things they want to talk about, encouragements, some helpful things to watch out for in the future, what people like hearing, what they don't like hearing. So we're really appreciative of all that. Glad to know you guys are out there and there's other people on the other end of these microphones. Yeah, definitely. I mean, we have added like all of the requests to the to our list of programming languages to cover. We want to sort of like cover sort of a variety of languages and sort of mix it up between the common ones and some of the more uncommon um but we definitely have taken all the feedback and we're
他们想听到的，他们想谈论的事情，鼓励，未来需要注意的一些有用的事情，人们喜欢听什么，不喜欢听什么。所以我们非常感谢所有这些。很高兴知道你们在那里，在这些麦克风的另一端还有其他人。是的，绝对。我的意思是，我们已经将所有的请求添加到了我们的编程语言覆盖列表中。我们想（你知道）覆盖各种语言，并在常见的和一些不太常见的之间进行混合，但我们绝对已经采纳了所有的反馈，并且我们
definitely going to keep uh covering languages until we've gotten every request out the door so definitely keep definitely and beyond so definitely keep uh keep sending us your feedback we really appreciate it if you have any particular show topics that you want to cover like if you're really interested in uh like you know embedded stuff and you want patrick to give like a little tutorial on how to make like an rc car or something or if you're interested in like games or ai or whatever i mean if you have any requests or any special topics you want to hear definitely shoot us a shoot us a post on the g plus um and we'd be happy to respond to that all right well that's a wrap thank you very much cool see you guys later the intro music is
绝对会继续（你知道）覆盖语言，直到我们完成了每一个请求，所以绝对保持，绝对，甚至更多。所以绝对保持（你知道）继续给我们发送你的反馈，我们非常感谢。如果你有任何你想要覆盖的特定节目主题，比如如果你真的对（你知道）嵌入式东西感兴趣，并且你想要 Patrick 给出一个关于如何制作像 RC 汽车之类的小教程，或者如果你对游戏或 AI 或任何东西感兴趣，我的意思是，如果你有任何请求或任何你想要听到的特殊主题，一定要在 G Plus 上给我们发个帖子，我们很乐意回应。好了，总结一下，非常感谢。酷，回头见。片头音乐是
axo by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Biner Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混音、改编作品，但你必须向 Patrick 和我提供署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。